sie werden dran gewesen aber jetzt ist
der Kollege dran
wollen sie noch mal tauschen ich meine
wir können hier alles machen Herr
mittelbergkamp sind sie außerorden also
nochmal Erklärung
hier sollte eigentlich der erste Redner
ein anderer sein als Volker Ulrich
Matthias Mittelberg nämlich der war aber
gerade nicht da deswegen hat man
getauscht und jetzt wieder
zurückgestellt also jetzt Matthias
Mittelberg für die Unionsfraktion
Kolleginnen bitte meine Unachtsamkeit zu
entschuldigen
in diesen Tagen in dieser Woche ist ein
Buch veröffentlicht worden von zwei
investigativjournalisten Oliver schröhm
und Oliver Hollenstein das heißt die
Akte Scholz der Kanzler das Geld und die
Macht so haben wir diese aktuelle Stunde
benannt aber das ist nicht der
eigentliche Anlass das ist vielleicht
der letzte Anlass um dieses Thema hier
in diesem Hohen Hause zu diskutieren man
könnte auch sagen gibt es nicht andere
Themen aber ich glaube es hängt schon
sehr auch mit den aktuellen Anspannungen
zusammen dass die Frage
an den wichtigsten Vertreter dieser
Regierung gestellt und seine
Glaubwürdigkeit und seine Integrität
betreffend dass diese Frage hier
diskutiert werden muss und in dieses
Haus gehört und der weiterreichende
Anlass
der weiterreichende Anlass ist dann eben
das Auftreten unseres heutigen
Bundeskanzlers und früheren Hamburger
Bürgermeisters Olaf Scholz vor dem
Untersuchungsausschuss in Hamburg sein
Schweigen seine faktische
Aussageverweigerung dort in der bis
heute nicht geklärten Steuersache
Warburg
der Auftritt der ich sage das so
deutlich wandelnden Erinnerungslücke
Olaf Scholz ist wirklich bemerkenswert
er will sich an nichts erinnern keinen
Details im Zusammenhang mit der
Steuersache Warburg gleichzeitig will er
sich aber sehr präzise daran erinnern
dass er in dieser Sache keinerlei
politischen Einfluss genommen hat ein
Widerspruch in sich
und dabei sind die Indizien und das sage
ich sehr deutlich dabei sind die
Indizien die mittlerweile schon auf dem
Tisch liegen und durch dieses neue
vorgelegte Buch erhärtet werden
bemerkenswert Hamburg war damals das
einzige der 16 Bundesländer dass die
cum-ex-rückforderungen nicht gestellt
hat dass die Gelder nicht zurück wollte
alle anderen 15 Bundesländer haben die
Gelder zurückgefordert Hamburg unter
Olaf Scholz hat es nicht getan da stellt
die Frage nach seiner politischen
Verantwortung
wir haben in den letzten Monaten auch
erfahren dass im Hause des damaligen
dann Finanzministers Olaf Scholz
Unterlagen zusammengetragen werden
sollten für den Untersuchungsausschuss
in Hamburg und dabei Ängste
Mitarbeiterinnen
E-Mails schrieben mit dem Inhalt mit
Olaf Seider noch zu diskutieren wie wir
die Termine mit kaspavelschick und
schenscher einsortieren es ging also
offensichtlich darum dass Beweismittel
für einen Untersuchungsausschuss
einsortiert werden sollten ein höchst
bemerkenswerter und im Zweifel auch
unzulässiger Vorgang
Kontakte zwischen Herrn Scholz und Herrn
Carsten aufzuklären wir haben erfahren
dass eine Steuer Beamtin die zuständige
in Hamburg in intern also ehrlichen
Nachrichten von einem teuflischen Plan
gesprochen hat der dort umgesetzt worden
sei indem man auf die Rückforderung der
Millionen verzichtete das alleine ist
für sich schon ein bemerkenswerter und
höchst aufklärungsbe Politiker Vorgang
und zum Schluss und ich will das nur mal
ganz plastisch erklären herr Scholz
verweist ja immer darauf ihr könnt mir
das bis ins letzte noch nicht nachweisen
aber de facto sind schon die äußeren
Umstände aussagekräftig genug er sagt
ich wollte mich nicht einmischen
dann führt man vielleicht mit den
Beteiligten einmal ein Gespräch und
erklärt ihnen ich will ich kann ich darf
mich nicht einmischen alles in Ordnung
was aber stattgefunden hat war dass er
sich dreimal mit den Chefs der
warburgbank in seinem Amtszimmer in
seinem Büro getroffen hat um ihn ich
weiß nicht wie begriffsstutzig diese
Banker waren um ihm drei Mal jeweils
eine Stunde lang zu erklären dass er
sich nicht einmischen will und dem
chefbänker olearius hat Olaf Scholz dann
noch von sich aus hinterher telefoniert
um ihm wahrscheinlich noch mal zu
versichern möglicherweise hatten die
Banker ist immer noch nicht verstanden
nach diesen Gesprächen dass er sich
nicht einmischen will dann hat er den
einen noch mal angerufen um ihm noch mal
zu versichern ich will mich nicht
einmischen und zur Erhärtung seiner
Absicht hat er dann noch die Empfehlung
ausgesprochen ich kenne noch jemanden
anderen der sich auch nicht einmischen
will nämlich den Herrn schenscher der
ist hier Finanzsenator und weil ich so
genau weiß und gar nicht so genau weiß
dass der sich auch nicht einmischen will
gebe ich euch den Tipp schickt mal eure
Unterlagen an den Herrn schenscher dann
könnt ihr sicher sein dass es keinerlei
Einmischung gibt wir wissen wie genau
nach diesen Gesprächen der Sachverhalt
ausgegangen ist das nämlich die
Hamburger Behörde die eigentlich die
Gelder zurückfordern wollte dann
plötzlich gesagt hat wir machen das doch
nicht also hier spricht jetzt alles
dafür und das ist unser Anliegen dass
wir diesen Vorgang ganz intensiv weiter
aufklären müssen herzlichen Dank
viel Applaus von der Unionsfraktion hier
für Matthias im Mittelberg der hier die
aktuelle Stunde eröffnet hat Michael
schrodi kann nun die Position der
Sozialdemokraten hier erläutern
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren gestern hat
die Ampelkoalition in der Aktuellen
Stunde darüber gesprochen wie wir die
Gaspreis
Bremse jetzt implementieren wie wir
Menschen in dieser Situation schützen
heute hat die cdu/csu eine Aktuelle
Stunde aufgesetzt in der sie mit einem
Buch beschäftigt in dem alte
Unterstellungen neu aufgewärmt werden
deutlich jetzt nicht zu zeigen welche
Prioritäten die einzelnen Fraktionen
setzen meine sehr geehrten Damen und
Herren
drei Anmerkungen zum Sachverhalt cum-ex
war immer kriminell zweimal betrug um
ex-geschäfte waren auch immer
illegal es gab auch keine Gesetzeslücke
Olaf Scholz war zu der Zeit der
cum-ex-betrügereien weder Hamburger
Bürgermeister noch war er
Bundesfinanzminister als
Bundesfinanzminister
hat er
Gesetze zur Einziehung von cum-exgeldern
und zur präventiven Bekämpfung von
cum-ex-betrügereien auf den Weg gebracht
wir wollten auch eine nationale
Anzeigepflicht für
steuergestaltungsmodelle auf den Weg
bringen um genau solche trügereien auch
aufzudecken das hat damals die cdu/csu
verhindert wir werden es
ampelkonditionen jetzt machen mal
schauen wie sie es dann zustimmen werden
oder ablehnen meine sehr geehrten Damen
und Herren
es gab keine politische
Einflussnahme auf ein Steuerverfahren in
Hamburg vor der Hamburg-Wahl 2020 wurden
diese Unterstellungen platziert als Olaf
Scholz Kanzlerkandidat wurde erneut
jetzt auch wieder stets mussten
Medienvertreter wie auch die Politik am
Schluss einräumen da ist nichts es ist
nun seit zwei Jahren ein
Untersuchungsausschuss in Hamburg
eingerichtet die Akten wurde hin und her
gewälzt und es wurden Zeugen von Nomen
vielleicht fragen Sie Herr Mittelberg
auch mal ihre Hamburger Kollegen die
Auskunft ist doch ganz einfach kein
einziger Hinweis oder Beleg für eine
politische Einflussnahme steht in den
Akten und wurde jemals von einem Zeugen
oder erzeugen dort eben zu Papier
gegeben ich wiederhole beziehungsweise
ich erinnere der Spiegel sechste Achter
Finanzbeamtin entlastet Olaf Scholz
4.3.2022 NTV staatsan Wald schützt
finanzamtsentscheidung zu warburg-band
und ich zitiere nochmal er sei mit der
Entscheidung damals absolut da Chor
gewesen sagte der Kölner
Oberstaatsanwalt Alexander Fuchs
deutlicher ist gar nicht das bestätigt
ist es gab eben keine Einflussnahme zu
eine fachliche Entscheidung der
Finanzbehörde Hamburg in engen Austausch
mit der Staatsanwaltschaft Köln nehmen
Sie das zur Kenntnis meine sehr geehrten
Damen und Herren
drittens der letzte verbliebene
Strohhalm für alle die Olaf Scholz etwas
anhängen wollen ist nun ein Protokoll
das Finanzausschusses vom Juli 2020 in
dem vermeintlich es Widersprüche gibt zu
den Aussagen mit den Treffen mit der
vakuumpbank wegen des hohen Guts des
Steuergeheimnisses ist sowohl die
Sitzung wie auch das Protokoll von der
damaligen Ausschussvorsitzenden als
geheim eingestuft worden Passagen sind
dort geschwärzt um eins klarzumachen die
SPD will die entstufung die Freigabe sie
will die entschwertung dieses
Protokolls wir wollen Transparenz
Offenheit und Klarheit meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren der zuständige
Ausschussvorsitzende der jetzt dafür
verantwortlich ist zu Endstufen und zu
entschmerzen wurde am 1 September
beauftragt vom finanz bis Ende September
einen Vorschlag für die endstufung
vorzulegen das ist bis heute nicht
erfolgt meine sehr geehrten Damen und
Herren
und am 1.10 stand im Spiegel
die Warburg Bank will nun auch
den Bundestag vom Steuergeheimnis
entbinden was dazu führen würde dass wir
entwärzten und Endstufen können wir
haben als Ampelkoalition noch einmal den
Ausschussvorsitzenden angeschrieben und
gesagt ist nun was gemacht worden damit
wir weiterkommen bei der entschwertung
in endstufung nein das ist nicht
passiert es wurde kein Kontakt bisher
aufgenommen übrigens der
Ausschussvorsitzende gehört der
cdu/csu-fraktion an meine sehr geehrten
Damen und Herren wir gehen davon aus
dass der Ausschussvorsitzende zeitnah
ein endschwertes und endstuftes
Protokoll vorbereitet dann müssen wir in
zukünftigen aktuellen Stunden der
cdu/csu uns nicht mehr mit
Unterstellungen und Nebelkerzen
beschäftigen sowie den sorgen Anlegen
der Bürgerinnen und Bürger
so
ich komme jetzt erstmal zurück zu
Tagesordnungspunkt 17a die Zeit für die
namentliche Abstimmung ist jetzt schon
drei Minuten vorbei draußen höre ich
gibt es auch keine Menschen mehr die die
Abstimmung an der Abstimmung teilnehmen
wollen deswegen frage ich im Saal hier
scheint das anders zu sein
da gibt es noch Kolleginnen und Kollegen
die gerne an der namentlichen Abstimmung
teilnehmen möchten
der nächste Redner hat noch nicht
abgestimmt okay dann verlängere ich die
Abstimmung bis die Möglichkeit für den
nächsten Redner gegeben ist auch noch
abgestimmt zu haben da geht es um den
Antrag der Linksfraktion zum Thema
Stromsperren bei Zahlungsunfähigkeit die
möchte die Fraktion verhindern aber
recht Glaser spricht jetzt erstmal für
die afd-fraktion bevor er dann abstimmt
der Herr Bundeskanzler spricht von
haltlosen Schauermärchen im Kern geht es
bei dem cum-ex-skandal um den
wahrscheinlich größten Steuerbetrug in
der Geschichte
dabei ist mindestens ein zwei ein hoher
zweistelliger Milliardenbetrag in
Deutschland hinterzogen worden auch die
Commerzbank die WestLB die HSH Nordbank
die Deutsche Post die KfW
Volkswagen und andere Unternehmen mit
öffentlicher Beteiligung stehen im
Verdacht sich daran beteiligt zu haben
die Staatsanwaltschaft in Köln ermittelt
mit 19 Staatsanwalt Teams gegen rund
1000 Verdächtige der Schwerpunkt der
betrügerischen Manipulationen fand in
den Jahren 2009 bis 2011 statt
es geht um Manipulationen bei
sogenannten cum-ex-geschäften was ist
das bei Dividendenzahlungen wird
automatisch die Kapitalertragssteuer
einbehalten bestimmte Empfänger von
Dividenden sind von dieser Steuer
freigestellt und können sich deshalb den
steuerbetracht vom Finanzamt zurückholen
diese Möglichkeit der Steuererstattung
wird mit hoher Raffinesse missbraucht
und damit der Fiskus betrogen das
Bankhaus Warburg in Hamburg war zwischen
2007 und 11 auf diesen Geschäftsfeld
sehr aktiv es hat sich 169 Millionen
erschlichen wie ein Wirtschaftsprüfer
formuliert davon sei ein großer Teil der
Forderungen inzwischen verjährt
im Jahr 2016 droht ein weiterer Betrag
von 47 Millionen zu verjähren die müsste
ja jeden Umstände dabei haben mit der
Person des damaligen Ersten
Bürgermeisters nach Malibu
Bundesfinanzminister und heutigem
Kanzler zu tun
urplötzlich beginnt eine Betriebsprüfung
des zuständigen Finanzamtes die
Rückforderung zu überdenken schreibt der
Buchautor Hund der sich jahrelang mit
der Causa Scholz beschäftigt Sie
kontaktiert den Anteilseigner der Bank
olearius und dieser bezieht an
alfonsik führen zweiten Bürgermeister
wegen seiner Kontakte zu Scholz ein
beides Mitglieder der feinen
Gesellschaft der Hansestadt parallel
hierzu wie der bundeshaushaltspolitiker
Kars als Lobbyist in Berlin mandatiert
das ist der mit den roten Wollsocken der
im Deutschen Bundestag unablässig die
AFD mit Invektiven attackierte man
könnte auch sagen um im Milieu zu
bleiben mit Schmutz und Schund bewahrt
in dessen Schließfach fanden sie später
200.000 Euro von bis heute ungeklärter
Herkunft da wir fest an die
Unabhängigkeit der Hamburger Justiz
glauben wird der Vorgang sicherzüglich
aufgeklärt es wurde in dieser Zeit auch
eine parteispender an die SPD von der
Bank von eben dieser Betroffenen Bank in
Höhe von 45.000 Euro getätigt in 2017
wurde einem leidende Beamten des
Bundesfinanzministeriums die noch nicht
verehrte Steuerforderungen gegen die
warburgbank die Höhe von 47 Millionen
bekannt
deshalb intensiv insistierte dieser
Mitarbeiter darauf dass die Hamburger
Behörde die Verjährung verhindern müssen
mit einem förmlichen Erlass ein relativ
ungewöhnlicher Vorgang erkennen Sie
hierüber ergaben sich durch Ermittlungen
der Staatsanwaltschaft Köln in Hamburg
wurde überhaupt nicht in der
mittelstrafrechtlich dort tauchten in
Köln Tagebücher von olearius auf in
denen von Treffen mit Scholz und den
Aktivitäten von Cars und pawelt schick
die Rede ist
zwei Gespräche von Scholz mit olearius
erfolgten ohne Zeugen und ohne
Niederschlag in den Akten in den
Büroräumen des Ersten Bürgermeisters
dies war deshalb prickelnd weil der
Finanzminister zuvor jegliche
persönliche Treffen mit olearius
bestritten hat ich selbst war Zeuge
eines solchen dementes im
Finanzausschuss
der tüchtige Beamte der Schaden vom Land
abwenden wollte wurde nach der
Amtsübernahme von Scholz in Berlin
überraschend frühpassioniert und die
Steuerforderungen in Höhe von 47
Millionen viel in die Verjährung
das ist also kein haltloses
Schauermärchen sondern beschreibt meine
sehr verehrten Damen und Herren die Lage
der Nation
genauso verhält es sich mit der inneren
Sicherheit mit dem Schutz vor
Massenzuwanderung der daraus
resultierten Lager Wohnungsmarkt den
Staatsfinanzen den Bildungssystem der
Energieversorgung der beute-system im
öffentlichen Dienst entgegen dem
Leistungsprinzip nach Artikel 33
insbesondere auch in der Justiz und mit
der notleidenden Meinungsfreiheit
die Anerkennung für diesen Staat und die
Demokratie insgesamt meine Damen und
Herren schwindet messbar seit Jahren
dazu gibt es unendlich viele
Meinungsumfragen nicht weil die Bürger
schlechte Demokraten sind soll weil die
politische Aufgabe weil die politische
Klasse ihre Aufgabe nicht erfüllt
dieser Staat wird nicht von Bösewichten
delegitimiert mein letzter Satz wie die
Innenminister ausgeschlossen
und den bewusst herbeigeführten der
bewusst herbeigeführten Verzicht auf die
kulturelle Identität in diesem Land
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
vielen Dank Herr Kollege Glaser sie
haben jetzt noch Gelegenheit ihre Stimme
weil der Name abzugeben
[Applaus]
da sieht der letzte Sinn sozusagen dann
lassen wir das momentan noch zu aber ich
würde Sie bitten dass dort ein bisschen
zu beschleunigen denn wir müssen
geschlossen werden die Zeit nehmen
moment mal die Zeit können wir
überbrücken durch einen Antrag der
afd-fraktion Herr Kollege Brandner hat
einen Wunsch
herr Präsident meine Damen und Herren
ich habe keinen direkten Wunsch ich habe
einen Antrag zu Geschäftsordnung und
zwar nach reparagraph 42 der
Geschäftsordnung wir haben einen richtig
wichtigen Antrag hier zu behandeln oder
eine Aktuelle Stunde durchzuführen auf
Antrag der Fraktion der CDU CSU die
ersten drei Redner haben gesprochen wir
haben den Eindruck als wenn die einiges
aufzuarbeiten ist was möglicherweise
auch dazu führen kann das Bundeskanzler
Scholz wieder Erinnerungslücken
aufführen kann deshalb beantrage ich für
die afd-fraktion die Herbeirufung des
Bundeskanzlers zu dieser Debatte
vielen Dank Herr Kollege in Brandner
die afd-fraktion verlangt den
Bundeskanzler zu zitieren dafür brauchen
wir die Mehrheit der anwesenden
Mitglieder des Hauses ich Frage wer den
Antrag der AFD unterstützt nämlich
Anzeichen
die afd-fraktion wer stimmt dagegen
das sind
die Grünen FDP in SPD und Linke wer
enthält sich die Unionsfraktion damit
ist der Antrag Herr Kollege Brandner
abgelehnt
das nennt man Demokratie als nächster
Redner als nächster Redner das Wort der
Kollege Sascha Müller Bündnis 90 die
Grünen und Sascha Müller ist ob man im
Finanzausschuss für die Grünen
Herr Kollege Müller ein ganz kleinen
Moment ich kann jetzt Herr Glaser hat
seiner Stimme abgegeben dann schließe
ich die Abstimmung und Frage noch einmal
ist ein Mittel des Hauses Anwesen dass
seine Stimme noch nicht abgegeben hat
das ist erkennbar nicht der Fall dann
schließe ich die Abstimmung und bitte
die Schriftführerin Schriftführer mit
der Ausbildung zu beginnen das Ergebnis
der Abstimmung wird Ihnen später bekannt
gegeben
so nun haben sie endlich das Wort der
Kollege Müller
Präsident sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
er gehört sicher zu den größten Fällen
an steuerskandalen in der Geschichte der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland der
steuerraub der mit den Schlagworten
cum-ex und kumkum bekannt wurde
vermutlich geht es allein im Fall
cum-exum über 10 Milliarden Euro der
Gesamtschaden für die öffentliche Hand
kann bis heute nur geschätzt werden es
handelt sich also direkt um einen Griff
in die Kassette der steuerzahler:innen
und damit dieser Fall auch am Ende
aufgeklärt werden konnte dafür haben
eine Reihe von Menschen Mut und
Hartnäckigkeit bewiesen und all ihnen
gilt unser besonderer Dank und ich
möchte in meiner Rede die Zeit nutzen
einigen zu danken da wären zuallererst
die wisselblauer die trotz des Risikos
beruflicher Nachteile die Behörden und
die Öffentlichkeit mit Informationen
versorgt haben und die erst so vieles in
Gang gesetzt haben was vermutlich
ansonsten unter der Decke geblieben wäre
sie konnten zeigen wie umfassend das
Problem steuerraub ist und welche Lücken
gestoppt werden müssen und genau deshalb
arbeitet diese Koalition auch an das
Gesetz zum besseren Schutz von
bisseblauern es wurde Zeit
da es wären weiterhin die es waren
weiterhin die betriebsprüferinnen und
Prüfer in der Finanzverwaltung die bei
diesen
kapitalertragssteuergetriebenen
Geschäften dran geblieben sind sich in
die komplizierte Materie reingefuchst
haben und am Ende nach jahrelanger
Kleinstarbeit genug Material
zusammengestellt haben um die
Anschuldigungen gerichtsfest machen zu
können in einigen Fällen benötigte es
benötigt es sag und schreibe sieben
Jahre Betriebsprüfung bis ein
Strafverfahren eröffnet werden und so
der Plünderung der Staatskasse Einheit
geboten werden konnte danke dass Sie
daran geblieben sind
ein großer Dank gilt auch den
Parlamentariern die sich hier in diesem
Haus in einem Untersuchungsausschuss
intensiv um die Aufklärung der Vorgänger
gekümmert haben für uns Grüne möchte ich
besonders meinen ehemaligen Köln oder
unser ehemaligen Kollegen Dr Gerhard
Schick nennen der heute an anderer
Stelle weiter wichtiger Arbeit für ein
transparentes Finanzsystem und so großen
Einsatz gegen Steuerbetrug leistet und
danke auch an den Untersuchungsausschuss
in der Hamburger Bürgerschaft der sich
ohne Rücksicht auf Personen ebenfalls
intensiv um Aufklärung bemüht ein großes
Dankeschön gilt auch an Korrektiv eV und
ja natürlich
natürlich auch an Oliver schröhm und es
ist für mich und ich war selbst war sehr
lange journalistisch tätig schwer
erträglich das gegen Herrn schröm für
seine damaligen Recherche dass dareus
größte vorgegangen wurde eine weitere
juristische Strafverfolgung ist man muss
ja fast sagen glücklicherweise im
sandverlaufen als Jahre später
Ermittlungen gegen die Redakteuren
Redakteure der Fernandel times
aufgenommen wurden dem Fall Wirecard
umgereimtheiten aufdecken es ist klar zu
sagen eine aufmerksame mit unter
unbequeme und kritische
Berichterstattung ist für ein Netz
funktionierende Demokratie so wichtig
auch bei der mühsamen Aufarbeitung von
cumex und auch wenn es zurweilen wie in
einem gerade zitierten neu erschienenen
Buch Bilder von uns Politikerinnen und
Politikern gezeichnet werden die wir
nicht teilen müssen aber die wir
aushalten müssen und ich bin mir sicher
die Beteiligten bzw der Beteiligte wird
das aushalten und wir als Ampelkoalition
haben ein gemeinsames Interesse die
Öffentlichkeit hat ein Recht auf
Aufklärung aller noch offenen Fragen und
unterstützen das und Kollege Schröder
hat schon darauf hingewiesen gerade
treiben wir gemeinsam auch wir als
ampelfraktion im Finanzausschuss
gemeinsam voran dass ein Protokoll aus
der zum Ende der letzten
Legislaturperiode aus dem
Finanzausschuss
entstuft wird und wir wollen das und wir
wirken auch gemeinsam darauf hin es geht
geht auch unter anderem um die
warburgbank ich möchte einmal kurz in
Erinnerung rufen die
warburg-stils in Eigenhandel sie ließ
sich so steuern erstatten schließlich
erklärte der Bundesgerichtshof im Juli
letzten Jahres dass die warburgbank dem
Bund 176 Millionen Euro für
cum-ex-geschäfte zurückzahlen muss meine
Damen und Herren liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen ein solcher Fall darf sich in
Deutschland nie wieder ereignen cum
ex-geschäft ist in den Deutschland
strafbar steuerraubt kann gestoppt
werden und er wird gestoppt werden es
geht schließlich um das Geld der
Menschen hier es geht um unser
Gemeinwohl wir brauchen dazu
schutzverbisse blauer bestmöglich
ausgestattete Finanzverwaltung und
Ermittlungsbehörden und natürlich auch
gute Gesetze damit die Behörden ihre
Arbeit nachgehen können es geht um das
Vertrauen in unseren Rechtsstaat lassen
Sie uns gemeinsam daran arbeiten ich
danke für die Aufmerksamkeit
Sascha Müller war das für die Grünen es
ist natürlich schwierig da an dieser
Transparenz zu arbeiten wenn es so Größe
große Erinnerungslücken gibt auch das
wurde hier schon viel kritisiert dass
dieser Fall nicht gerade von besonders
viel Transparenz Zeug Christian Görke
spricht jetzt für die Linksfraktion der
finanzpolitische Sprecher
die investige tiefer Recherche der
Journalisten Strömen und Hollenstein die
heute Gegenstand der Aktuellen Stunde
ist belegt 1 es gab und es gibt Filz
zwischen industriellen zwischen Bankiers
und der Politik in der Freien und in der
Freien Hansestadt Hamburg zur Wahrheit
gehört auch am Mittelberg das kann ich
nicht ersparen dass sie als CDU in der
Zeit von Ole von wolf-spendenzahlungen
aus der Warburg Bank erhalten haben dass
nur mal zur Vollständigkeit aber ich
komme jetzt mal zu den
Sozialdemokraten die auf dem Höhepunkt
der Steueraffäre aus dem weit geweigten
Konzernbereich von Christian eularius
und Max Warburg mal mehrere 10.000 Euro
auf die Kasse überwiesen bekommen haben
ich will an dieser Stelle gar nicht auf
die von der Staatsanwaltschaft im
Bankschließfach von Johannes Kaas
gefunden
240.000 Euro Bargeld eingehen
Zusammenhänge Fragezeichen ist das
Zufall wir werden sehen was das für
undurchsichtige ex-geschäfte sind hat
mein damaliger Kollege Fabio De Masi
hier ganz zutreffend im Parlament mal
auf den Punkt gebracht ich gehe in den
Supermarkt gebe eine Bierflasche ab
nehme ein Pfandbon legen dann auf den
Kopierer und lasse dann mit meinen
Freunden diesen ganz häufig mir an der
Kasse ausbezahlen mit dem Unterschied
dass sie Supermarktkasse das Finanzamt
ist und das bei cum-ex es nicht um den
Flaschenpfand geht sondern um Milliarden
im Ergebnis
der größte Steuerbetrug in der
Nachkriegsgeschichte mit diesen dubiosen
Finanzgeschäften haben Banken
Großinvestoren in deutsche Staat und
sage und schreibe
35,9 Milliarden Euro Bedrohungen mit
diesem Geld meine Damen und Herren
könnte man zum Beispiel in diesem Winter
jeden privaten Haushalt die Gasrechnung
übernehmen meine Damen und Herren im
Fall der Privatbank Warburg geht es aber
um mehrere hundert Millionen Euro die
Staatsanwaltschaft Köln beschuldigt
Herrn olarius der Steuerhinterziehung
mittlerweile sind die Urteile über
ehemalige Mitarbeiter der Bank gefällt
die müssen hinter Gittern und die in
warburgbank musste 176 Millionen an die
Staatskasse zurückführen auch die 47
Millionen Euro auf die merkwürdigerweise
die Hansestadt Hamburg kurioserweise
verzichten wollte und heute aus meiner
Sicht nach wie vor ein Schatten auf den
damaligen Ersten Bürgermeister und heute
im Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz werfen
deshalb erwartet nicht nur das Parlament
und meine Fraktion sondern auch die
Menschen offen daraus da draußen dass
hier endlich
Tacheles geredet wird und vor allem
reiner Tisch gemacht wird um Fragen zu
Folge
wollen fast 80 Prozent der Menschen da
draußen dass sich der Bundeskanzler
ausführlich zu diesen
70 Prozent kaufen ihm auch seine
Erinnerungslücken nicht ab und ich
glaube und ich glaube im übrigen er hat
sich auch wirklich im Widersprüche
verheddert und die neueste
buchveröffentlicht die Akte Scholz gibt
einiges davon zum besten eine dieser
Widersprüche ist meine Damen und Herren
das im Herbst 2020 eher in diesem Hause
sagte sie könne sich nicht vorstellen
wie zu irgendeiner Zeit irgendjemand der
diese Geschäfte verstanden und mit ihnen
zu tun gehabt habe tatsächlich annehmen
konnte dass er etwas legales tut und
dennoch traf er sich
dreimal mit Christian solarius
wohlgemerkt zu einem Zeitpunkt als
bereits er Beschuldigter in einem
Ermittlungsverfahren war und die Razzia
in der warburgbank stattgefunden hat ein
anderer Widerspruch ist dass Olaf Scholz
als Erster Bürgermeister den
herrnullarius empfohlen hat das
verteidigungsschreiben der warburgbank
obwohl sie es schon in der
Steuerverwaltung lag von oben über den
Finanzen in norddeutsch Tschentscher
politisch einzuspen was dann auch noch
mit einer Abzeichnung passiert das
Ergebnis ist bekannt und das ist dass
das keine Sonderbehandlung ist meine
Damen und Herren
das können die Menschen draußen
sicherlich ganz schnell verstehen und
ich sage Ihnen auch als ehemalige
Finanzminister kann ich so etwas auch
nicht verstehen und meine Damen und
Herren der SPD
sorgen Sie dafür dass ich ihr
Bundeskanzler erinnert und dass er sich
ehrlich macht und vor allen Dingen dass
er sich der Befragung im Finanzausschuss
endlich stellt es wäre nach der
Veröffentlichung des Buches die Akte
Scholz glaube ich ganz gut beraten
vielen Dank
der ehemalige Finanzminister
Brandenburgs war das
die Aktuelle Stunde um sie und der
Tagesordnungspunkt 17a über das Ergebnis
der namentlichen Abstimmung über die
Beschlussempfehlung des Ausschusses für
Klimaschutz und Energie zu dem Antrag
der Abgeordneten Amira Mohammed Ali dr
Gesine Lötzsch gökei Akbulut weitere
Monate und der Fraktion DIE LINKE Strom
und gastsparen verbieten Drucksachen
2026 86 und 20 38 53 zu unterrichten
abgegebene Stimmkarten 643 mit ja haben
gestimmt 603 mit Nein haben gestimmt 37
Enthaltungen 3 damit ist die
Beschlussempfehlung angenommen wir
kehren nun zurück zur aktuellen Stunde
und das Wort hat der Kollege Markus
Herbrand FDP-Fraktion
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident ich habe
mich als erstes gefragt welche Rechte
denn die Union an dem Buch hat also man
kann ja im Grunde genommen eine bessere
pr-veranstaltung zwei Tage nach
Erscheinen dieses Buches gar nicht haben
ich danke aber den unionskollegen und
Kolleginnen sehr für die Gelegenheit
dieses skandalakte cumex und kumkum
heute noch mal aufzurollen dabei ist die
Fixierung auf den Bundeskanzler Olaf
Scholz als oppositionsreflex der Union
natürlich sehr nachvollziehbar
allerdings sollten wir auch nicht darauf
reinfallen wir müssen durchaus auch
weitere Hintergründe und
Verantwortlichkeiten dieses Skandals
benennen dabei wird klar dass die Union
besser nicht nur mit dem Finger auf
andere zeigen sollte manchmal ist auch
der Blick in den Spiegel durchaus
angebracht
worüber wir reden ist jetzt vielfach
ausgeführt worden noch unter dem
ehemaligen bundesfinanzminister Wolfgang
Schäuble ereignete sich der größte
steuerbetrugskandal in der Geschichte
der Bundesrepublik Deutschland
Gauner haben sich viele Milliarden Euro
durch sogenannte
cum-ex-betrügereien vom Fiskus also von
uns allen erschlichen
erschreckenderweise war das BMF unter
seinem damaligen Minister erst in den
Jahren 2012 und 2016 nach jahrelanger
Untätigkeit zu dem Entschluss gekommen
den Betrug ein Ende zu setzen so wurden
2012 cum-ex-geschäfte verboten und noch
einmal vier Jahre später folgten dann
kumkum alleine durch diese Verzögerung
sind Schätzungen zur Folge nochmals
mehrere Milliarden Euro für den
deutschen Fiskus verloren gegangen
alle Beteiligten und die und der
politisch Verantwortliche Finanzminister
wussten also spätestens seit 20 20 11
das Betrüger rein im Milliardenbereich
laufen und dennoch vergehen bis zu fünf
Jahren bis der Geschäfte macherei ein
Riegel vorgeschoben wird seit vielen
Jahren beschäftigen wir uns nun im
Parlament mit der Aufarbeitung der
damaligen fehlerketten in den
Regierungsjahren der großen Koalition
war an dieser Stelle leider wenig
Enthusiasmus zu erkennen die in die
Opposition gewechselte Union scheint
aber endlich bereit zu sein auch die
eigene unrühmliche Verantwortung für den
jahrhundertbetrug an den
Steuerzahlerinnen und Steuerzahlern
aufzuarbeiten
selbstverständlich gehört dabei auch die
Frage nach Verantwortlichen auf allen
Ebenen auf den Tisch das Parteibuch darf
dabei einer lückenlosen Aufklärung nicht
im Wege stehen nur durch vollständige
Transparenz bei allen Beteiligten kann
verloren gegangenes Vertrauen wieder
zurückgewonnen werden auch Bundeskanzler
Olaf Scholz muss diesem Anspruch gerecht
werden und darüber aufklären was er wann
wusste und was er genau wann getan hat
dasselbe gilt aber selbstverständlich
auch für den ehemaligen Finanzminister
Wolfgang Schäuble und die jeweils
verantwortlichen Fachminister auf
Landesebene ich freue mich sehr über den
offenkundigen Willen der Union auch
diese für Sie sicherlich eher unbequem
Fragen endlich anzugehen dasselbe gilt
aber auch für den Bundeskanzler mit
seinen bisherigen Ausführungen zu diesem
Themenkomplex hat er aus meiner
Perspektive nachvollziehbar dargestellt
wie er sich in seiner Zeit als Erster
Bürgermeister von Hamburg Verhalten hat
sollte es darüber hinaus allerdings
Aspekte geben die zur Aufklärung
beitragen müssen diese natürlich
ebenfalls offengelegt werden auch Olaf
Scholz selbst sollte ein großes
Interesse daran haben den Diskussionen
und Verdächtigungen und mit maximaler
Transparenz entgegenzutreten
die FDP-Fraktion wird dabei niemanden
vorverurteilen allerdings bekommt von
uns auch niemand einen Freifahrtschein
wir arbeiten daher sowohl im
Finanzausschuss als auch in Abstimmung
mit dem Bundesfinanzministerium an der
Offenlegung aller Details zum
cum-ex-skandal die Akte Warburg ist
dabei ein wichtiger ein wichtiges
Puzzleteil welches auch durch
möglicherweise weitere Beiträge von Olaf
Scholz an die richtige Stelle gerückt
werden sollte herzlichen Dank
vielen Dank Herr Kollege Herbrand
und der nächste Redner ist Volker Ulrich
erster rechtspolitische Sprecher der CSU
Landesgruppe und natürlich dadurch auch
Mitglied in der Unionsfraktion
[Applaus]
herr Präsident meine
sehr verehrten Damen und Herren wir
leben in
herausfordernden Zeiten für
demokratische Institutionen und die
Stärkung der Glaubwürdigkeit in diese
und ihre zentralen Repräsentanten ist
eine der wichtigsten Fragen dass der
cum-ex und kumkum-skandal insgesamt
weiter aufgearbeitet werden muss ist
selbstverständlich es geht aber um
spezielle Fragen im Warburg Scholz
Skandal und diese dürfen wir nicht
einfach wegdiskutieren die Hamburger
Finanzbehörde hat die März 2016 vor
Ablauf der Verjährungsfrist die
Möglichkeit nicht genutzt zu Unrecht
erstattete Kapitalertragsteuer in Höhe
von 47 Millionen Euro von der Warburg
Bank zurückzufordern im Jahr 2017 wurden
weitere 43 Millionen Euro erst nach
zweimaliger Weisung durch
Bundesfinanzministerium von Seiten der
Hamburger Verwaltung
zurückgefordert die Übernahme von
politischer Verantwortung für diesen
Komplex ist bis heute ungeklärt und das
fordern wir ein
der heutige Bundeskanzler hat sich im
Zeitraum von September 16 bis November
17 insgesamt drei Mal mit dem Chef der
Hamburger Warburg Bank getroffen und ihm
sogar telefonisch geraten eine
Stellungnahme aus Sicht der Privatbank
an den damaligen Finanzsenator
Tschentscher zu schicken die
Öffentlichkeit hat von diesen Treffen
aufgrund der Auswertung sichergestellt
hat Tagebücher des Beschuldigten
bankmanagers erfahren dass der heutige
Bundeskanzler selbst die Anzahl der
treffen nämlich drei nicht von sich auf
sondern nur auf Vorhalt und schrittweise
einräumte ist wenig transparent und
enttäuschend
wer ein Amt an der Spitze einer
Regierung hat der muss sich die freie
gefallen lassen und sie beantworten
weswegen er mehrmals den Chef einer Bank
trifft gegen den bereits zu diesem
Zeitpunkt wegen schwerer
Steuerhinterziehung ermittelt wird und
weshalb eine Rückforderung der
Finanzbehörde im Raum steht politisch
klug war das nicht der Bundeskanzler hat
ausgeführt dass er keine konkreten
Erinnerungen an diese Treffen haben das
müssen wir zur Kenntnis nehmen der Punkt
ist aber auch dass sie gesagt hat er
habe auf jeden Fall
politisch keine Einflussnahme
herbeigeführt die Frage ist also
erinnert sich nicht an die treffen aber
daran dass keine Einflussnahme
stattgefunden hat beides passt nicht
zusammen hier muss Aufklärung erfolgen
wir haben ein Staats politisches
Interesse daran
dass in Krisenzeiten unser Land durch
sachlich richtige und moralisch
gefestigte politische Führung regiert
wird
ein zumindest in groben Zügen
vorhandenes Erinnerungsvermögen an
Termine und Sachverhalte aus jungen
Vergangenheit ist eine Eigenschaft die
man von einem Bundeskanzler verlangen
muss
es darf nicht das Bild bleiben der
Bundeskanzler habe an nicht unerhebliche
Sachverhalte keine Erinnerung im
Interesse seiner eigenen Glaubwürdigkeit
sollte der Bundeskanzler diesem Eindruck
nachdrücklich entgegenwirken die bitte
geht also heute von diesem Haus an die
Bundeskanzler geben Sie der Transparenz
und der Aufklärung im Sinne der
Glaubwürdigkeit den Vorzug gegenüber
Erinnerungslücken und vergessen
dass diese Aufklärung Not tut und dass
die Einforderung von Transparenz zentral
ist muss auch im Interesse der
regierenden Koalition sein schließlich
heißt es auf Seite 9 des
Koalitionsvertrags und ich zitiere mit
Erlaubnis das Präsidenten wir wollen
doch mehr Transparenz unsere Demokratie
stärken uns leiten die Prinzipien
offenen Regierungshandelns Transparenz
Partizipation und Zusammenarbeit dieser
Anspruch an Transparenz muss in der
Sache Warburg und im Komplex nicht
zurückgeforderte Steuerschuld eindeutig
eingelöst werden das ist eine Frage der
Glaubwürdigkeit unserer Demokratie
insgesamt die aktikum Ex darf nicht
geschlossen werden bis nicht auch dieser
Warburg komplett aufgeklärt ist und da
bitte ich und die Mitwirkung aller die
daran beteiligt sind herzlichen Dank
die Aufforderung von Volker Ulrich war
das hier noch einmal
diesen Skandal aufzuklären bisher ist es
doch sehr unbefriedigend was man offen
offiziell darüber weiß Tim klissen
klyssendorf jetzt für die SPD-Fraktion
die Aktuelle Stunde ist ja ein
parlamentarisches Mittel was wirklich
wichtig ist wir haben hier Gelegenheit
außerhalb von Gesetzesvorhaben und
Anträgen über Themen zu diskutieren die
wirklich von relevant sind die aktuell
von Bedeutung sind für die Menschen in
unserem Land und die möglicherweise auch
von unseren Debatten dann profitieren
können indem wir den Meinungsaustausch
auch noch mal darlegen als wir davon
erfahren haben dass sie eine Aktuelle
Stunde einberufen wollen habe ich mir
überlegt okay was könnten Themen sein
die hohen Preise vielleicht die
Energiekrise möglicherweise die
Situation im Iran die Situation in der
Ukraine die Raketenangriffe vielleicht
alles nicht die aktuelle Stunde die sie
einberufen haben geht um ein Buch ein
Buch das keinerlei Neuigkeiten bringt
über die Erkenntnisse die bereits
vorliegen keinerlei neuen Informationen
das eigentlich nur das zusammenträgt was
bereits bekannt ist und jetzt muss ich
mal ganz ehrlich über ihre
Oppositionsarbeit sprechen Friedrich
Merz und deswegen habe ich mir das Zitat
auch noch mal ausgedruckt um das auch
korrekt zu zitieren hat am 1 März ich
weiß ja sie mögen das nicht wenn man
Herrn Merz an seine märzren erinnert hat
am 1 März gesagt konstruktive Opposition
heißt die Regierung zu kritisieren wo es
nötig ist ihr Alternativen
gegenüberzustellen wo es möglich ist ihr
aber in schwierigen Lagen auch zu helfen
das Land zu regieren das ist dann unser
gemeinsamer Erfolg da hat er recht sie
haben ganz recht der Künstler da hat er
recht nur gehen wir mal das Zitat durch
konstruktive Opposition heißt es die
Regierung zu kritisieren wo es nötig ist
sie kritisieren nicht die Regierung sie
kritisieren auch nicht das
Regierungshandeln hier sie kritisieren
überhaupt nichts an hindertlicher
Politik die gerade läuft sie kritisieren
etwas was in einer Finanzbehörde in
Hamburg alles was durch mehrere
Ausschüsse einem Untersuchungsausschuss
in Hamburg untersucht worden ist ein
Finanzausschuss der Deutschen
Bundestages und sie beschäftigen sich
überhaupt nicht mit der Politik und den
Herausforderungen in diesem Land
kommen wir zum zweiten Punkt ihr
Alternativen gegenüberzustellen wo es
möglich ist wo stellen sie
Regierungspolitik hier Alternativen
gegenüber Ihre aktuelle Stunde
beschäftigt sich ja auch nicht damit wie
man aus cum-ex lernen kann das was zum
Beispiel der Kollege Herbrand oder der
Kollege Müller oder der Kollege schrody
dargelegt hat wie wir mit cumex anders
umgehen können welche inhaltlichen
Schlussfolgerungen daraus gezogen sind
sie fokussieren sich allein darauf
Erinnerungslücken hier und klare
Aussagen da sie beschäftigen sich
überhaupt nicht mit den Inhalten das
Schlimme an dem commex-skandal sind doch
die entgangenen Steuergelder und nicht
das Verhalten in irgendwelchen
Ausschüssen sondern was wir daraus
lernen und wie wir nach vorne blicken
können
und jetzt komme ich zum letzten Punkt in
dem Zitat ihres Oppositionsführers ihr
aber in schwierigen Lagen auch zu helfen
das Land zu regieren wenn man ganz
ehrlich ist die ganzen letzten Wochen
und Monate konstruktive
Oppositionsarbeit wurde eingestellt das
einzige was sie tun und das hat die
niedersachsenwahl auch schon gezeigt ist
die Ampel anzuschießen und die Regierung
zu destabilisieren und das tun sie mit
einem Kalkül dass das wohl dieses Landes
in den Hintergrund geraten lässt und das
allein parteipolitisch dominiert ist das
ist nicht nur das ist einfach komplett
am Thema vorbei es ist überhaupt nicht
der Verantwortung gerecht die die als
größte Oppositionspartei haben sie
degradieren sich mit dieser aktuellen
Stunde zu einer personifizierten
Verkaufsförderungsmaßnahme für ein Buch
und nichts anderes sonst es geht nur um
Inhalte es gibt Null um das Land
das ist dann unser gemeinsamer Volk ist
der letzte Satz und es ist neben nicht
unser gemeinsamer Erfolg sie haben sich
schon lange von der konstruktiven
Oppositionsarbeit verabschiedet es kommt
keine Vorschläge es kommen solche
aktuellen Stunden in der letzten Woche
war schon die Aktuelle Stunde Klarheit
und Führung es gibt keine inhaltlichen
Themen sie versuchen hier den
Bundeskanzler bei zu zitieren wahlweise
an habe ich herbei zu zitieren obwohl er
gleichzeitig im Haushaltsausschuss auf
ihre eigenen Fragen antwortet es ist
Woche für Woche das gleiche ich bitte
Sie wirklich bringen Sie eigene
Vorschläge lassen sie uns inhaltlich an
den Sorgen und Nöten der Menschen
diskutieren lassen sie uns gemeinsame
Arbeit für dieses Land machen und dann
geht's auch gemeinsam voran so ist es
kein gemeinsamer Volk so ist es nur ein
Erfolg der ampelregierung wie dieses
Land regiert wird und nichts anderes
vielen Dank
vielen Dank Herr Kollege kirstendorf
nächste Redner ist der Kollege Dr
Sebastian Schäfer Bündnis 90 die Grünen
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident sehr
geehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen
organisierter Steuerbetrug in
Milliardenhöhe ist ein Verbrechen ein an
unserer Gesellschaft ein Verbrechen an
unserem Staat
dem kann nur mit voller Transparenz und
lückenloser Aufklärung begegnet werden
da geht es zum sachorientierte
sale und mühevolle Arbeit und
selbstverständlich darf es dabei keine
Schonung geben das haben die
bundestagsuntersuchungsausschüsse zu
cum-ex und zu Wirecard gezeigt dazu
gehört aber auch dass im Rahmen der
schärfsten Schwerter die wir als
Parlamentarierinnen und Parlamentarier
haben weder mit Vorverurteilungen noch
mit vorweggenommen freisprechen
gearbeitet wird
ich frage mich was genau der aktuelle
Anlass der Debatte heute ist eine
parlamentarische Buchbesprechung als
Freund der deutschen Gegenwart Literatur
hätte ich da noch noch viele Ideen ich
empfehle zum Beispiel ganz besonders
identity von metoo Sunshine aber ich
fürchte für parlamentarische
Buchbesprechungen sind wir nicht gewählt
wenn wirklich neue Informationen
auftauchen dann gehören die
selbstverständlich aufgeklärt und
aufgearbeitet dass allseits als gut
recherchiert beschriebene und viel
gelobte Buch die Akte Scholz ich habe es
noch nicht komplett lesen können bringt
nach meinem Kenntnisstand jedoch keine
wirklich neuen Erkenntnisse das macht es
nicht weniger interessant denn es stellt
zusammenhängend da und hilft beim
Verständnis und ich möchte hier
unterstreichen wie wichtig die Arbeit
der
investigativen JournalistInnen wie
Oliver schröm und Oliver auch
Hollenstein ist wie viele Finanzskandale
wären ohne JournalistInnen in den
letzten Jahren deutlich unter der
wahrnehmungschwelle geblieben oder wären
irgendwann still und heimlich unter den
Teppich gekehrt worden Panama leaks
Wirecard oder P&R die Liste ist leider
sehr lang
die Aufdeckung bei vielen der Skandalen
ist letztlich übrigens nur ins Rollen
gekommen weil es Whistleblower innen mit
gewissen gab die großes Risiko
eingegangen sind warum erwähne ich das
die große Koalition hat die Einführung
eines effektiven whistleblowerschutzes
in Deutschland verhindert und die Ampel
hat ein hinweisgeberschutzgesetz
ordentlich ins Deutsche übersetzt auf
den Weg gebracht dass bald den
parlamentarischen Prozess durchlaufen
haben wird
wurde umfassend in einem
Untersuchungsausschuss im Bundestag
behandelt auf Initiative von Bündnis 90
die Grünen wir wollten und wollen volle
Transparenz und Aufklärung aber im
Rahmen von
parlamentarischen Prozessen und nicht
den schaufensterdebatten eben weil es um
die Aufklärung des größten deutschen
steuerraubs geht wir wollten
herausfinden wo staatliche Strukturen
versagt haben um sie für die Zukunft zu
verbessern ich will insbesondere an die
großen Verdienste von Gerhard schicker
erinnern der mit der finanzwende das
Thema jetzt mit Mitteln der
Zivilgesellschaft weiterhin intensiv
bearbeitet
leider wurden damals die
untersuchungsausschussunterlagen einfach
abgeheftet das ist zu wirklichen
Reformen bei der Aufsicht und den
staatlichen Strukturen kam dafür hat es
dann noch den Wirecard Skandal gebraucht
laut Schätzungen des Steuerexperten
Christoph spengel von der Uni Mannheim
ist uns allen seit der Jahrtausendwende
durch cum-ex-geschäfte ein Schaden von
mindestens 10 Milliarden Euro entstanden
und leider ist es die absolute
Untergrenze der Schadensumme davon kommt
bisher nur ein Bruchteil von etwa 1,4
Milliarden Euro gesichert werden das
Kapitel cum-ex ist auch juristisch
keineswegs abgeschlossen die
Staatsanwaltschaft Köln und das
Landgericht Bonn werden diese
Steuerhinterziehungen noch Jahre
beschäftigen aktuell sind erst einige
wenige der Betrüger verurteilt worden
die Ampel wird weiter an Maßnahmen gegen
missbräuchliche Steuergestaltungen
arbeiten und auch den Daten und
Informationsaustausch zwischen
Finanzaufsicht und Steuerbehörden bei
Verdachtsfällen ermöglichen dabei geht
es nicht nur um den Reputationsschaden
für unseren Rechtsstaat für unser Land
sondern auch um Steuereinnahmen um
Steuersubstrat dass wir zur Bekämpfung
der multiplen Krisen dringend benötigen
herzlichen Dank
vielen Dank Herr Kollege Dr Schäfer
[Applaus]
nun lauschen wir den Ausführungen des
Kollegen Matthias Hauber
cdu/csu-fraktion
herr Präsident meine sehr verehrten
Damen und Herren Deutschland steht vor
riesigen Herausforderungen allein schon
der russische Krieg gegen die Ukraine
die unsicheren Versorgung mit Energie
die explodierenden Preise Deutschland
bräuchte jetzt ein Bundeskanzler der
ehrlich führt und dem die Menschen
vertrauen können doch Deutschland hat
Olaf Scholz
der Steuerskandal cum-ex steht für
Milliarden Euro um den kriminelle
unseren Staat und damit uns alle in
Deutschland betrogen haben und dieser
Skandal zerstört jeden Tag mehr die
Glaubwürdigkeit des Bundeskanzlers das
Buch die Akte Scholz der Kanzler das
Geld und die Macht enthüllt neue
Erkenntnisse es unterlegt bekannte
Vorwürfe mit weiteren Fakten und es
wirft weitere Fragen an den
Bundeskanzler auf während 15
Bundesländer gegen diesen steuerraub zu
Felde gezogen sind
und auch versucht haben das geraubte
Steuergerät zurückzuholen hatten die
cumexkriminellen in Hamburg
Narrenfreiheit unter dem ersten
bürgermeister Olaf Scholz ob in Hamburg
oder im Bund ich erwarte von einem
Regierungschef dass er sich nicht mit
steuerkriminellen trifft dass er ihnen
keine Tipps gibt und dass er Ihnen
stattdessen klipp und klar sagt ihr
kommt mit eurem steuerraub nicht
ungeschoren davon aber das Gegenteil hat
Olaf Scholz getan und nicht nur
und nicht nur bei Comex ist die
Glaubwürdigkeit des Bundeskanzlers auf
einem Tiefpunkt zwei aktuelle Beispiele
erstens in der Generaldebatte sagte der
Bundeskanzler kürzlich er würde alle
Probleme schon lösen bevor andere sie
überhaupt nur erkennen wie kann man nur
so anmaßend seiner Bundeskanzler
zweitens Putin nutzt Energielieferungen
als Waffe dazu äußerte sich der
Bundeskanzler vorgestern er sagte
wortwörtlich Zitat ich war mir immer
sicher dass er das tun würde Olaf Scholz
will also die Gas Erpressung durch
Russland vorausgesehen haben wieso hat
er da nicht gegengesteuert Olaf Scholz
war jahrelang Arbeitsminister
Finanzminister Vizekanzler und sogar als
Scholz schon Kanzler war als russische
Truppen schon an der ukrainischen
Ostgrenze aufmarschiert waren da
verteidigte er immer noch Nord Stream 2
wer will den Bundeskanzler eigentlich
sowas abstruses glauben und nur beim
Hamburger Steuerskandal
da will Scholz sich an nichts mehr
erinnern und dabei werden immer mehr
offene Fragen aufgedeckt warum hat Olaf
Scholz mehrfach die Steuerbetrüger in
seine Amtsstube empfangen sie angerufen
ihn sogar Tipps gegeben anstatt das
Steuergeld einfach zurückzuholen wieso
musste das Bundesfinanzministerium mit
zwei Weisungen das von Scholz geführte
Bundesland zwingen die Steuermillionen
zurückzuholen gab es wie die
Staatsanwaltschaft erwägt eine Zitat
koordinierte Löschung von E-Mails und
sollten Zitat
Führungspersonen bewusst von
Verantwortung ferngehalten werden indem
diese nicht per E-Mail kontaktiert
werden
und was ist eigentlich aus dem
Versprechen des
spd-chefhaushälters Johannes Kaas an die
Banker geworden dass man den warburgfall
wieder aufrufen werde wenn die SPD das
Bundesfinanzministerium übernehmen werde
kurz danach übernahm Scholz das
Ministerium und dann musste genau der
Abteilungsleiter gehen der durch die
Weisungen die Steuer Millionen vor der
Verjährung gerettet hat er wurde mit 59
Jahren unter Scholz in den vorläufigen
Ruhestand versetzt
und bis Juli 2020 da konnte sich der
Bundeskanzler an zumindest eintreffen
erinnern da hat er sogar dreimal drüber
gesprochen erst kurz danach als
investigative Journalisten weitere
Treffen aufgedeckt haben beginnen seine
Erinnerungslücken wieso kann sich Scholz
seitdem auch an das erste Treffen
eigentlich nicht mehr erinnern hat Olaf
Scholz die Unwahrheit gesagt immerhin
hat sogar seine Familienministerin einst
wortwörtlich mehrfach gesagt Zitat
stolzert den Bundestag belogen Zitat
einer grünen wieso hat Olaf Scholz den
warburg-bänkern den Tipp gegeben ihr
Schreiben an den Finanzsenator zum
Senden obwohl ihm das Schreiben längst
vorlag jedenfalls wollte direkt danach
die Hamburger Behörde die steuermillion
plötzlich dann doch verjähren lassen
Zufall wohl kaum und wieso steht Olaf
Scholz eigentlich auf der dankesliste
die der warburg-chef handschriftlich
angefertigt hat vier von zehn Namen sind
auf der Liste sogar abgehakt der
Steuerberater sowie drei SPD-Politiker
Johannes Karst über den haben wir schon
eine Menge gehört gerade Alfons
pawelschik spd-prominenz aus Hamburg mit
üppigen Lobbyismus honoraran von Warburg
und als dritter Bundeskanzler Olaf
Scholz alle diese Fragen sind offen
dennoch schweigt Olaf Scholz auch heute
die Ampelkoalition hat mit der
Regierungsübernahme das
aufklärungsinteresse verloren das haben
wir heute auch gemerkt aber wir werden
die Akte Scholz nicht schließen Herr
Bundeskanzler es liegt an Ihnen endlich
für Klarheit zu sorgen vielen Dank für
die Aufmerksamkeit
vielen Dank Herr Kollege Hauer und damit
kommen wir zum nächsten Reden an der
vorletzte Redner in dieser aktuellen
Stunde
als nächster Redner kommt zu uns der
Kollege Frank Müller Rosentritt
FDP-Fraktion
ja sehr geehrter Präsident sehr geehrte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen das Journalist
Sebastian Hult hat vorgestern auf n-tv
ein Online-Beitrag veröffentlicht mit
dem Titel ist Scholz ein Lügner es hat
sich daran mit dem neuen Buch die Akte
Scholz der Kanzler das Geld und die
Macht auseinander und bereits in der
unterüberschrift heißt es einen
schlagenden Beweis für Scholz
Verstrickungen in die cum-ex-affäre
bleiben die Autoren schuldig
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen der Union
auch wenn das Erscheinen eines Buches
hier ein eher nachrangiger Anlass für
eine Stunde ist steht es Ihnen
selbstverständlich nur pluralen und
lebendigen Demokratie als
oppositionsreflex zu so zur Verfahren es
ist allerdings schon äußerst verwegen
dass das über Jahre von ihrer Partei
geführte Bundesfinanzminister Bruder
Wolfgang Schäuble jahrelang diesem
illegalen Treiben oder darum gesehen hat
und am Ende stellen Sie sich hier im
Bundestag hin und mach den ehemaligen
Ersten Bürgermeister Scholz zu zeigen
aber sie wissen doch jetzt am besten
wenn sie mit einigen Finger auf Urlaub
Scholz zeigen zeigen Sie mit drei Finger
auf sich zurück deshalb unglaublich und
von 2009 bis 2017 war Wolfgang Schäuble
den ich übrigens als in der letzten
Wahlperiode als Bundestagspräsident sehr
schätze Finanzminister von 2011 an
wusste man für diesen unfassbaren
Gebaren und erst kurz vor dem Ende
seiner Zeit also Finanzminister wurde
letztendlich all diese Geschäftsgebaren
verboten da kann ich nur sagen Wolfgang
Schäuble komm temporär
liberale stehen für das Rechtsprinzip
und auch die Steuergerechtigkeit ein
dazu zählt für uns dass wir Straftaten
auch konsequent verfolgen möchten und
ich möchte an dieser Stelle mein
geschätzten Kollegen Florian Tonga
zitieren mit Erlaubnis des Präsidiums er
sagte am 9 September 2020 hier an dieser
Stelle in der Debatte cum-ex
steuerdealster Politik als Vertreter der
Oppositionsfraktion FDP an die Adresse
des damaligen Bundesfinanzminister
Scholz ich zitiere ich unterstelle dass
das was wir inzwischen von ihnen
erfahren haben vollständig ist und dass
das wir und das wir nicht auf weitere
Dinge stoßen die den bekannt waren die
aber bisher nicht genannt worden sind
das ist glaube ich auch eine Frage des
Respekts wo parlamentarischen
Institutionen Zitat Ende einer
Aufarbeitung dieser cum-ex-geschäft oder
Warburg Bank der Beteiligung oder eben
nicht Beteiligung des damaligen
Hamburger Bürgermeister Scholz fand
statt findet statt und wird auch so
lange stattfinden wie sich Anschuldigen
und Beweise ergeben sollten aber die
Unschuldsvermutung geht eben auch für
einen ehemaligen Ersten Bürgermeister
Hamburg aber legen Sie dies bitte eben
nicht als in dubio pro reo aus denn auch
wenn viele Zweifel an der Sache hegen es
gibt eben aktuell kein Angeklagten Olaf
Scholz eine Strafanzeige gegen Olaf
Scholz schaltet den zweitens tanzen nach
der Staatsanwaltschaft sieht auch die
Generalstaatsanwaltschaft Hamburg keinen
anfassverdacht auf mögliche Beihilfe zur
Steuerhinterziehung und
wer steht auch völlig zu Unrecht unter
Generalverdacht und darauf möchte ich
auch eingehen das ist dann auch durch
diese eine Verfehlung einer Bank die
Bankenbranche an sich getreu dem Motto
alle Banken betrügen dabei sind das doch
die Banken die zentraler Bestandteil der
Wirtschaft sind welche das Geld für die
Finanzierung zur Verfügung stellen über
90 Prozent aller Investitionen in
Deutschland werden von privaten
Investoren Unternehmen getätigt und mit
Hilfe unserer Banken finanziert und
deshalb sollte man in diesen Zeiten
alles dafür tun um diesen Motor im Laufe
zu halten und Banken gerade in ohnehin
rezessiven Zeiten nicht mit zusätzlichen
Kapitalanforderungen belasten die
drohenden enormen Zusatzbelastung durch
den antizyklischen und sektoralen
Kapitalpuffer welche zu Zeiten beste
Konjunktur ausgedacht wurden um eine
Überhitzung zu vermeiden legen die Axt
an zukünftige Finanzierungen welche aber
gerade bei der Transformation eine
nachhaltige Wirtschaft in die Schaffung
von Wohnraum sowie die Bildung von
Wohneigentum dringend benötigt werden
hunderte Milliarden Euro an Kapital
werden der Markt somit nicht zur
Verfügung stehen oder Kredite werden
durch den Regulator zusätzlich zu den
ohnehin schon gestiegenen Zinsen so
teuer dass das fast unmöglich wird die
verabredeten 400.000 Wohnungen die wir
bauen wollen zu bauen meine Damen und
Herren der Union das das was ich gerade
ausgeführt habe das wäre mal eine
Aktuelle Stunde Wert die die Wirtschaft
und das Land nach vorne bringen würde
anscheinend reden wir heute über ein
Buch wie klein kann man sich eigentlich
nur machen Liebe Union wobei die
Fähigkeiten von Autoren Strömen und
Hollenstein in keinster Weise hier heute
in Abrede stellen möchte und entgegen
den grundzeiten im Finanzministerium
wird das BMF und noch besser Lindner und
sein Team um Katja Hessel und Florian
Tonka den Kampf gegen Finanzkriminalität
im Gegensatz zu ihm deutlich ausweiten
dazu bündeln wir Kompetenzen unter dem
Dach einer neuen Behörde außerdem
stärken wir die finnische Intelligence
Unit als zentrale Stelle für Geld welche
Verdachtsmeldungen unterrichten auch
eine neue Zentralstelle für Geldwäsche
Aufsicht die Aufsicht auch über den
nicht-finanzsektor koordiniert das BMF
will und dafür bin ich den
Finanzminister sehr dankbar
steuerferndes stärken und insbesondere
schwerere Fälle der Steuerhinterziehung
und aggressive Steuergestaltung
bekämpfen ein letzter Satz in eigener
totaler Sache könnten wir die Parade
überall die Finanzen selbst verwalten
und bewachen hätten wir nicht wie bei
ihnen cum-ex sondern das Prädikat zum
laute vielen Dank
nun denn ich habe nicht damit gerechnet
Kollege müller-hosentritt dass sie mal
gibt ja noch schneller reden kann als
ich und jetzt in einer mir völlig
unbekannten Sprache
bevor der Kollege Dr Jens Zimmermann das
Wort hat muss ich zurückkommen zu den
Wahlen
die Zeit für die Wahlen ist vorbei ist
noch ein Mitglied des Hauses anwesend
dass seine Yahoo aber
sie dürfen jetzt auch gerne
also darf ich darf ich mal darauf
hinweisen das mache ich jetzt gerne dass
er sehr viel Zeit hatten und
also ich finde die Unionsfraktion
wirklich ziemlich beeindruckend mit dem
was jetzt Geschäftsordnung nichts
passiert ich kann unterbrechen wir sie
jetzt gewählt haben aber ich kann auch
sagen wir lassen immer noch hören und
dann gehen sie zur Urne wie wir es
vorhin beide Glaser gemacht haben
salomonisch in Abwandlung der zwingende
Vorschriften der Geschäftsordnung
entscheide ich das jetzt einfach mal so
als letzter Redner hat das Wort der
Kollege Dr Zimmermann SPD-Fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident das ist
sehr großzügig wer auch schade gewesen
wenn der Hauer jetzt hätte dich zu hören
können danke für das Interesse meine
Damen und Herren liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen das Buch die Akte Scholz wurde
am 11.10 veröffentlicht darüber reden
wir in dieser aktuellen Stunde und die
Begründung die die Union mitliefert ist
durch das Buch bestimmten nun offene
Fragen und ich würde mal sagen das ist
eine reichlich steile These denn kaum
ein Thema und das haben wir in dieser
Debatte jetzt auch schon erlebt ist
eigentlich so umfangreich beleuchtet
worden wir haben mehrere
Untersuchungsausschüsse gehabt es gibt
unzählige Veröffentlichung gefühlt vom
Pförtner in der Hamburger Bürgerschaft
bis zum Finanzminister wurden dutzende
und aber dutzende Zeugen und Zeugen
Untersuchungsausschüssen gehört fast
zwei Jahre parlamentarischer
Untersuchungsausschuss in Hamburg es hat
sich am Ende eine Sache gezeigt Olaf
Scholz hat keinen Einfluss auf das
Steuerverfahren der Warburg Bank
genommen meine Damen und Herren
denn was ist eigentlich die Frage dieses
ganzen propans der hier aufgeführt wird
die Frage ist gab es im Jahr 2016 eine
politische Einflussnahme auf die
Entscheidung der Finanzbehörden in
Hamburg und war deren Entscheidung in
Sachen Warburg Bank damals richtig und
es ist ja wichtig dass man sich bei
dieser zentralen Frage ein Bisschen auch
mal auf all das stützt was die
Untersuchungsausschüsse was sie denn
alles so zu Tage geführt haben alle
Zeugen der Finanzbehörde haben ausgesagt
alle diejenigen die dieses
Steuerverfahren geführt haben haben
ausgesagt es gab keinerlei Beeinflussung
durch die Politik sie hätten sich
eigenständig und ausschließlich an
fachlichen Gesichtspunkten entschieden
in den Akten und das ist ja das Schöne
an Untersuchungsausschüssen da kann man
die ganzen Akten herbeiziehen in den
Akten finden sich ebenfalls keinerlei
Anhaltspunkte für diese These wenn sich
die Aussagen der Beamtinnen und Beamten
im Untersuchungsausschuss anschaut mit
den aktenvergleicht alles deckt sich
also demnach kann man feststellen die
Beamtinnen und Beamten hatten keinen
Zweifel damals das zum damaligen
Zeitpunkt wir reden über 20 16 das ist
sehr sehr wichtig das ist damals eben
rechtlich nicht sicher gewesen wäre
diese Rückforderung damals zu stellen
das ist das was die Akten und die
Ergebnisse der Untersuchungsausschüsse
zu Tage geführt haben meine Damen und
Herren
und diese Geschichte die sie hier immer
erzählen von wegen 15 von 16
Bundesländern wir müssen ja immer ein
bisschen zurückgehen in 2016 fakt ist
Hamburg hat 2020 das Geld
zurückgefordert und ich finde es gibt ja
es gibt ja einen es gibt ja aus meiner
Sicht einen absoluten Kronzeugen der
über jeden Zweifel erhaben ist und das
ist der Kölner
Oberstaatsanwalt Fuchs also der oberste
cum-ex-jäger des Landes von 20 16 und 17
der musste ja auch Aussagen vor dem
Untersuchungsausschuss und solche sagen
was der gesagt hat zum Verhalten der
Hamburger Steuerbehörden er hat
wortwörtlich gesagt ich war mit dem
Verhalten vollkommen dakor also er war
vollkommen einverstanden mit dem Handeln
der Hamburger Steuerbehörde das sagt ein
Kölner
Oberstaatsanwaltschaft der oberste
cum-ex-jäger der ist nicht aus Hamburg
der hat nicht mal wie andere
Staatsanwältin sp die Parteibuch sondern
der hat gesagt das war richtig ich war
davor damit liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
und das interessante an der Sache ist
dieser Oberstaatsanwalt hat im
Untersuchungsausschuss ausgesagt dass
der Fall damals noch nicht ausreichend
ausermittelt gewesen ist und das ist ihm
eigentlich recht war dass die Hamburger
das nicht zurückgefordert haben er sah
er begründet es deswegen hätten die
damals mit einem halb garen Fall das
gemacht und sie hätten vor Gericht
verloren wäre die ganze
cum-ex-geschichte einfach so
weitergegangen das sagt ein ehemaliger
Oberstaatsanwalt in dieser Sache und ich
finde das muss man doch mal zur Kenntnis
nehmen liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
ich fasse zusammen es gibt trotz
umfangreichster Ermittlungen
keinerlei Beweise die Finanz die
Finanzverwaltung beteuert nicht
beeinflusst geworden zu sein der oberste
cum-ex-jäger der Jahre
2016/17 sagt die Haltung war vollkommen
richtig insofern kann ich mit einem Satz
aus diesem Buch Enden das nämlich der
letzte Satz in diesem Buch da war nichts
es hat keine Einflussnahme gegeben
schönen Dank auch das war von Olaf
Scholz
vielen Dank Herr Kollege Dr Zimmermann
damit schließe ich die Aktuelle Stunde
und so das war jetzt etwas uneindeutig
da gab es doch viel Uneinigkeit ob eben
in diesem neuveröffentlichten Buch ist
und Neuigkeiten gibt zum cum-ex ist
Skandal und dadurch hat man hier nicht
so ganz auf der gleichen Basis
diskutiert wir kommen jetzt zum nächsten
Tagesordnungspunkt der auch schon viel
diskutiert wurde es geht um die 300 Euro
energiepauschale für Menschen im
Ruhestand
das ist ein Teil des dritten
entlastungspaketes
Ruhestand sowie auch
Versorgungsempfänger des Bundes denn wir
erinnern uns diese waren ja beim
Entlastungspaket beim zweiten
Entlastungspaket leer ausgegangen das
hatte für einen großen Aufschrei zurecht
gesorgt und jetzt wird eben
Sozialminister Hubertus Heil hier noch
einmal nachlegen so dass zum ersten
dezember zum 15 Dezember diese 300 Euro
ausgezahlt werden sollen
sehr geehrter Präsident liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen seit dem 24
Februar erleben wir das Putin nicht nur
die Ukraine überfallen hat sondern
versucht die Staaten in Europa die die
Ukraine unterstützen
mit dem Einsatz von Energie als Waffe
wirtschaftlich und sozial zu
digitalisieren und das ist keine
Verschwörungstheorie des Westens sondern
das ist das was wir in redenden
Wladiwostok und in Reden in Sankt
Petersburg selbst gesagt hat er versucht
uns wirtschaftlich zu schädigen und uns
sozial auseinander zu treiben um unsere
Solidarität mit der freien und keine zu
zerstören aber das meine Damen und
Herren wird ihm nicht gelingen
und deshalb
tun wir alles um wirtschaftlichen
Schaden von diesem Land abzuwenden und
gleichzeitig unsere Gesellschaft sozial
zusammenzuhalten konkrete sind fünf
Dinge die wir tun das erste ist dass wir
für Versorgungssicherheit kämpfen den
vergaseinspeichern sehen wir dafür
sorgen dass energy Terminals gebaut
werden das ersatzbeschafft wird dass wir
eine gasnotlage möglichst in diesen und
im nächsten Winter verhindern das zweite
ist dass wir dafür sorgen dass die
Kosten runterkommen Stichwort gasbremse
und gaspreisbremsung strompreisbremse
ich bin sehr dankbar für die Empfehlung
der Kommission die uns mithelfen den
Schutzschirm von 200 Milliarden Euro so
auszuspannen dass wir tatsächlich mit
den Preisen runterkommen und damit
Bürgerinnen und Bürgern hinterlassen
entlasten und Unternehmen retten können
drittens meine Damen und Herren
Wirtschaftshilfen für vor allen Dingen
kleine mittelständische Unternehmen und
viertens Jahr auch das Instrument der
Kurzarbeit und wenn es notwendig ist um
Arbeitsplätze zu sichern und Brücken zu
bauen und wir entlasten Menschen mit
unteren und mittleren Einkommen mit den
entlastungspaketen und mit dem heutigen
Gesetz sorgen wir in zwei Bereichen für
sehr gezielte Entlastung zum einen meine
Damen und Herren sorgen wir dafür dass
die 20 Millionen Rentnerinnen und
Rentner die energiepauschale für 300
Euro noch Mitte Dezember diesen Jahres
bekommen können das hilft 20 Millionen
Menschen sehr sehr konkret wie es auch
verdient haben
und es geht zum Beispiel nicht nur um
die Rentnerin Rentner aus der regulären
gesetzlichen Rentenversicherung es geht
zum Beispiel auch um erwerbsgeminderte
in diesem Bereich die davon profitieren
werden ganz ganz wichtiges Signale
dieser Zeit zweitens meine Damen und
Herren wir sorgen auch dafür dass das
Geld tatsächlich die Einmalzahlung nicht
der Beitragspflicht in der
Sozialversicherung unterliegt das heißt
das Netto bei den Menschen mehr ankommt
und dass wir auch bei den
einkommensabhängigen Leistungen dieses
Geld nicht anrechnen werden es kann auch
nicht gepfändet werden ich will damit
eins sagen die Rentnerinnen Rentner
meine Damen und Herren können sich in
Deutschland auf den Sozialstaat gerade
in diesen Zeiten verlassen
weil wir heute morgen darüber geredet
haben im Zusammenhang mit der Debatte um
die Einführung des Bürgergeldes des
Arbeits sich in Deutschland lohnen muss
kümmern wir uns auch um die Menschen mit
geringen Einkommen nicht nur durch die
Erhöhung des Mindestlohns auf 12 Euro ab
1 Oktober diesen Jahres in Kraft
getreten nicht nur indem wir Steuern
senken und dafür sorgen dass im übrigen
der Kinderzuschlag eingeführt wird dass
das Kindergeld erhöht wird sondern auch
indem wir gezielt Menschen mit geringem
Einkommen mit diesem Gesetz von
Sozialversicherungsbeiträgen so
entlasten dass sie mehr in der Tasche
haben und gleichzeitig sich in ihrem
sozialen Schutz nicht verschlechtern wir
heben die berühmte minijob-grenze den
Übergangsbereich von 1600 auf 2000 Euro
auf das sorgt dafür dass wir die
Menschen in diesem Einkommensbereich um
insgesamt 1,3 Milliarden Euro entlasten
und das nicht nur im nächsten Jahr
sondern dauerhaft meine Damen und Herren
die Menschen haben es verdient und das
ist der richtige Weg
wir werden einige sagen 1,3 Milliarden
ist viel Geld aber individuell sind das
dann für jemand der 1000 Euro hat eine
Entlastung von monatlich 58 Euro das
sind ja nicht viel das sagen aber Leute
die sehr sehr viel höheres Einkommen
haben für Menschen in diesem
Einkommensbereich ist das ab 1 Januar
eine sehr sehr gezielte Entlastung
deshalb meine Damen und Herren bitte ich
Sie unterstützen Sie dieses Gesetz wir
helfen Rentnerinnen und Rentner wir
sorgen dafür dass Arbeitnehmer und
Arbeitnehmer mit geringem Einkommen mehr
Geld in der Tasche haben und es ist Teil
unserer Maßnahme diese Gesellschaft in
diesen Zeiten zusammenzuhalten
herzlichen Dank für Aufmerksamkeit
vielen Dank Herr Minister der
Bundesminister für Arbeit und Soziales
war das wie komme ich zurück zu den
Wahlen die Zeit für die Wahlen ist
abgelaufen mir ist mitgeteilt worden
dass die Kolleginnen und Kollegen aus
Unionsfraktion ihre Wahlentscheidung
haben treffen können damit erschließe
ich die Wahlen und bitte die
Schriftführung und Schriftführer mit der
Auszählung zu beginnen die Ergebnisse
der Wahlen werden Ihnen später bekannt
gegeben
so dann kommen wir zum nächsten Redner
dem Kollegen Max Straubinger
cdu/csu-fraktion
geschätzter herr Präsident Werte Damen
und Herren
ist beraten ja heute ein Gesetz des
bedeutet Zahlung einer
energiepreispauschale an Renten und
Versorgungsempfänger und auch an
Studenten das auch mit beinhaltet ist
und gleichzeitig ist auch damit
enthalten dass die midijob-grenze
ausgeweitet wird in der List sicherlich
ist es richtiger Bundesminister wie sie
einführend ausgeführt haben dass wir die
Menschen unterstützen in dieser Frage
des wirtschaftskriegs den letztendlich
und diese energiekriegs den Putin also
gegen unser Land führt und insgesamt
gegen Europa führt und da stehen wir
auch als Union mit dann ihrer Seite
aber wenn Sie dieses Gesetz einbringen
und sie wenig dazu eigentlich gesagt
haben sondern sehr viel über anderes und
ich mich an frühere Formulierungen
erinnern kann das Gute Kita-Gesetz hat
man mal das Gute Rentengesetz hat normal
das Gute so und so gesetzt hat man mal
dann würde ich dieses Gesetz
letztendlich überschreiben mit einem
schlechte gewissengesetz nämlich
es ist das schlechte Gewissen der
Bundesregierung und von natürlich den
ampelparteien weil sie beim ersten
Entlastungspaket
energieentlastungspaket die Rentnerinnen
und Rentner und die Studenten in unserem
Land außen vorgelassen haben und zwar
und zwar bewusst außen vor gelassen
haben obwohl sie sich immer in der
großen sozialen Verantwortung üben unter
auch natürlich großartig auch
formulieren wie sie die Menschen
unterstützen aber sie haben die
Rentnerinnen und Rentner in unserem Land
damals Herr Bundesminister
abgespeist mit der Erklärung wir haben
ja zum ersten siebten eine so tolle
große Rentenerhöhung gemacht mit 5,1%
und 6,1 Prozent im Osten und das hat
sozusagen also das genügt für die
Rentnerinnen und Rentner das war ihre
doch das war ihre die Frage seinerzeit
mit der Begründung die Rentnerinnen und
Rentner bei der energiepreispauschale
außen vorzulassen und deshalb sage ich
ganz bewusst dass dieser ein schlechtes
gewissengesetz ist
und dies wurde letztendlich nur dadurch
ermöglicht dass jetzt die Rentnerinnen
und Rentner ebenfalls eine Entlastung
bekommen weil der Druck von CDU und CSU
von der Opposition hier dies mit
herbeigeführt hat und vielleicht auch
das Wahlverhalten der Wählerinnen und
Wähler in Nordrhein-Westfalen und da
wollte man natürlich nicht jetzt in
Niedersachsen also unter Umständen sich
diese Gefahr auch noch also mit ausgeben
und deshalb hat sich diese
Bundesregierung und vor allen Dingen
dann die ampelfraktionen entschlossen
hier tatsächlich etwas für die
Rentnerinnen und Rentner zu tun Herr
Kollege Straubinger erlauben sie eine
Zwischenfrage aus der SPD-Fraktion
selbstverständlich bitteschön Kollege
Rosemann gerne
ja lieber Straubinger das ist ja immer
schön wenn sie so richtig in Fahrt sind
ja aber Wintergarten
der geht noch mehr aber ich finde es
auch bemerkenswert dass sie hier sich so
aufplustern und die cdu/csu so als
Partei der Rentnerinnen und Rentner
darstellen und da würde ich gerne
ja ich glaube da da seid ihr ein
bisschen falsch gewickelt da würde ich
nämlich gerne mal wissen wie das
eigentlich dazu passt dass in der großen
Koalition in den letzten vier Jahren wo
wir ja eine gemeinsame rentenkommission
hatten Herr Straubinger wo sogar die CSU
ne also in Person von Stefan Stracke
dabei war ja warum sich denn da die CDU
und CSU dagegen gewehrt hat gemeinsam zu
vereinbaren dass wir das Rentenniveau
auf 48% festschreiben wenn Sie die
Rentnerpartei wären dann hätten sie es
doch die Garantie des Rentenniveaus
damals mitmachen können haben sie nicht
gemacht in der Ampel haben wir das
gemeinsam hinbekommen und wenn sie die
Partei der Rentnerinnen Rentner sein
wollen dann hätte ich doch gerne auch
mal eine Haltung dazu wie Sie das
eigentlich so in Zukunft mit dem
Renteneintrittsalter sehen da haben wir
hier in der Ampel uns darauf verständigt
dass wir das Renteneintrittsalter nicht
weiter über 67 Jahre erhöhen da würde
mich mal ihre Position als Union dazu
interessieren nach meiner Kenntnis haben
sie da eigentlich keine also ich bin
sehr geehrter Herr Dr Rosemann vielen
Dank für die Frage ich bin da sehr
dankbar dass sie auf das
Renteneintrittsalter 67 hinweisen das
wurde ja eingeführt und einem
Bundesminister Franz Müntefering ich bin
dem ausserdrücklich sehr dankbar denn
denn Franz Müntefering der hatte
wenigsten Statur dafür die
Generationenfrage auch richtig anzugehen
und Sie können sich Herr Dr Rosemann vor
der generativen Entwicklung in unserer
Gesellschaft mögen sie sich
möglicherweise davon stehlen die ganze
Zeit aber die wird sie einholen die
werden die wird uns insgesamt einholen
als Gesellschaft wenn wir immer mehr
Rentnerinnen und Rentner und weniger
Erwerbstätige haben das ist ja völlig
klar Herr Dr Rosemann und Sie können sie
können es jetzt kaschieren sie können es
jetzt kaschieren ich bin da dass die FDP
die es mitmacht diesen Mist muss dieser
Bolz sagen das ist ja so also sie sie
wollen hier die generative Frage in
keinster Weise sachgerecht angehen und
das ist letztendlich also hier das
Versagen der Sozialdemokratie in dieser
neuen Zeit hätten wir mehr Frauen
Müntefering ist wie Hubertus Heil muss
ich sagen
Werte Damen und Herren es ist ja noch es
ist ja noch dazu dass es schlecht
gemacht ist also ich habe ja viel
Verständnis aber
Bundesminister hätten sie unserem Rat
damals schon gefolgt und seinerzeit die
Rentnerinnen und Renten auch die
energiepreispauschale ausgezahlt dann
gäbe es jetzt nicht so viele
Doppelzahlungen der kleine Rentner Markt
Straubinger der hat bereits schon 300
Euro über seinen Einkommenssteuer
Vorauszahlungsbescheid erhalten
und jetzt bekommt er nochmals 300 Euro
also es ist der unglaublich also 7
Millionen Rentnerinnen und Rentner sind
einkommensteuerpflichtig Zahlen
Vorauszahlung die haben bereits 300 Euro
erhalten und erhalten jetzt wieder 300
Euro also das ist ja unmöglich dass
gerade die Rentnerinnen und Rentner dies
eigentlich besser geht die Mehreinkünfte
haben die werden weiterhin zusätzlich
entlastet später wird wohl wieder
kassiert werden bei der Einkommenssteuer
aber diese Bürokratismus der hier
aufgebaut wird das ist ja unerträglich
verehrte Damen und Herren
und dann haben wir noch die schöne die
schöne Geschichte mit der Ausweitung der
Midijobs der Bundesminister sehr gelobt
dafür aber ich muss sagen
alle sagen wir dass in dieser Zeit wo
die Unternehmen so gefordert sind wo sie
Ängste haben gerade die kleinen
Unternehmen die auch viele
Teilzeitbeschäftigungen haben dass sie
jetzt letztendlich jede
Teilzeitbeschäftigung zu Midijob
erklären und damit die BürgerInnen und
damit die Unternehmen belasten laut
Ausweis des gesetzvorschlags werden die
Unternehmen mit zusätzlich 500 Millionen
Euro belastet wenn ich dann noch dazu
rechne dass er auch die Abführung von
Sozialversicherungsbeiträgen für die
Unternehmen ja bei der Anhebung auf 1300
Euro zwischen 1300 und 1600 Euro Minijob
ebenfalls hier die Unternehmen dann dies
machen mussten bedeutet das ein eine
zusätzliche Belastung für die
Unternehmen von 1,3 Milliarden Euro ich
frage mich was sagt da die
unternehmerpartei des FDP dazu überhaupt
dazu also diese Fragen die müssen wir
jetzt klären ich freue mich auf die
Anhörung und ich freue mich auf weitere
Debatten dazu herzlicher Dank Herr
Präsident herzlichen Dank für die
Aufmerksamkeit
das war also die Kritik der von Max
Straubinger und hier geht es gleich
weiter mit Markus Kurt sitzt jetzt im
Ausschuss für Arbeit und Soziales
Präsident liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
man weiß ja gar nicht wo man anfangen
soll wenn man die Rede eben gerade
gehört hat ich will auf jeden Fall schon
mal darauf hinweisen dass das zentrale
ist dass wir jetzt die Konjunktur auch
dadurch stärken indem wir versuchen
Kaufkraftverluste möglichst abzumildern
bei den Personen und da hat die FDP zum
Beispiel auch mit dem
Inflationsausgleich im Steuerrecht kalte
Progression unter anderem auch dazu
beigetragen das wollen wir der
Vollständigkeit halber mal nicht
verschweigen auch wenn es jetzt nicht
unser lieblingsanliegen war aber das
heißt wir haben in der Ampel insgesamt
dort zusammengearbeitet und
und der Bundesminister hat hier schon
eine ganze Reihe Punkte aufgezählt die
wir gemacht haben er hätte auch noch das
9 Euro Ticket zusätzlich erwähnen können
dass wir das Wohngeld ausweiten und
erhöhen er hätte die
strompreisbremse noch zusätzlich erhöhen
können also es gibt noch eine ganze
Menge andere Sachen Abschaffung der
EEG-Umlage wo diese Ampel
zusammengenommen für das gesamte
Spektrum des Einkommens von
SGB II beziehenden bis zu den
Werktätigen in der Mittelschicht alles
mögliche getan hat und das sollte man in
den Mittelpunkt dieser Debatte und der
Betrachtung stellen denn das die
energiepreispauschale für Rentnerinnen
und Rentner reiht sich in diesen
Maßnahmenkatalog ein
und wenn es Ihnen gut gefällt Herr
Straubinger das ist der Druck der Union
war warum wir das jetzt machen und wenn
ihr größter Kritikpunkt ist dass es
zugegebenermaßen verspätet gekommen ist
dann sei ihnen dieser Punkt von mir aus
ruhig gegönnt ich erinnere nur daran
dass ich vor einigen Monaten als ich von
dieser Stelle aus zu einem Antrag der
Union gesprochen habe wo Sie uns das
auch schon vorgeworfen hatten ich meine
Rede mit den Worten Schloss dass wir uns
beim nächsten Entlastungspaket um die
Rentnerinnen und Rentner kümmern werden
und genauso ist es jetzt auch gekommen
ich möchte lieber noch mal die Zeit
nutzen etwas anderes in die Betrachtung
mit einzuführen denn wir sehen ja dass
jenseits Bundeswehr Sondervermögen
Jenseits Übernahme von Juniper und
anderen Gasunternehmen in Summe alles
jetzt alleine an entlastungspaketen und
jetzt das was wir noch in diesen
wirtschaftssicherungsfond packen also
gaspreisbremse auf 300 Milliarden Euro
zuläuft das ist eine astronomische Summe
muss ich auch gerade als Haushälter im
Haushaltsausschuss sagen und trotzdem
gibt es sorgen allen halben trotzdem
erreichen uns ja auch verschiedene
Hilferufen und was zeigt uns das sollen
wir noch mehr Einmalzahlungen
Rettungsschirme Zuschläge und
Preisnachlässe machen
da wo es sinnvoll und notwendig ist
würde ich sagen ja schon zum Beispiel
wenn es darum geht eine vernünftige
Nachfolge zum neuen euro-ticket zu
finden wenn es darum geht Rehakliniken
oder stationäre Einrichtungen in der
Kinder- und Jugendhilfe stärker zu
unterstützen und andere Beispiele mehr
könnte ich nennen aber ansonsten bin ich
sehr dafür dass wir mit dem Prinzip
Gießkanne für die Zukunft Schluss machen
und dass wir zielgerichtet intervenieren
da wo das notwendig ist wir haben ja bei
krisenreaktionen immer einen klassischen
Zielkonflikt nämlich den zwischen
Schnelligkeit und Zielgenauigkeit und
weil wir es jetzt schnell gehen musste
weil diese Krise sich so aufgetürmt hat
ist es auch okay dass man sozusagen eine
breitbandantwort oder martialisch
Bazooka genommen hat aber wenn wir jetzt
in weiteren Schritt der
Krisenbewältigung gehen
dann muss man das auf jeden Fall
zielgenauer machen denn die Erfahrungen
lehrt dass man so mit
pauschalinstrumenten Glücksritter und
Krisengewinner anzieht ich erinnere nur
an die masken-dealer von der Union
während der coronakrise die das schamlos
ausgenutzt haben ja ist doch wahr
leugnen sich nicht es gibt Streuverluste
das ist auch bei der
energiepreispauschale der Fall weil es
tatsächlich auch Menschen bekommen die
ist nicht brauchen wie ich zum Beispiel
oder der Herr Straubinger und es gibt
Mitnahmeeffekte diejenigen die sich über
den Tankrabatt am meisten gefreut haben
dürften ja die Mineralölkonzerne gewesen
sein das heißt also mehr Zielgenauigkeit
in Zukunft ist absolut entscheidend
und diese
Höhe 300 Milliarden die scheinbar immer
für einige nicht reichen zeigt aber auch
das Ausmaß der Abhängigkeit in dass wir
uns begeben haben beim Thema billiges
Gas in diese wahnsinnige sucht und es
legt noch mal ganz deutlich die
Notwendigkeit offen dass wir die
Transformation zu einer klimaneutralen
Wirtschaft beschleunigen verdreifachen
vervierfachen müssen um uns aus diesen
fatalen Abhängigkeiten in die uns
frühere Bundesregierung geführt haben
endlich zu befreien
und
wir dürfen auch wirklich nicht vergessen
dass alle krisenausgaben jetzt auch
Ausgaben zur Stärkung der Demokratie
sind das möchte ich noch mal
ausdrücklich betonen weil ja zu
befürchten steht dass die Person die
nach mir reden wird von der Fraktion
hier ganz rechts außen behaupten wird
dass die
Energiekrise Resultat von deutschen
quasi wirtschaftskriegserklärungen ist
dass wir nur den USA folgen und ihre
Befehle ausführen und an dieser Stelle
muss einfach wie bei allen Maßnahmen die
wir hier zur Bewältigung in Gang setzen
klar sein dass wir dieses tun weil ein
Diktator Europa bedroht und die Ukraine
gewaltsam überfallen hat und damit
tatsächlich auch uns im gesamten Westen
eine Art von ich will nicht sagen
Kriegserklärung aber eine Bedrohung
Androhung ausgesprochen hat und das darf
man bei allem was vielleicht manchmal
noch ein bisschen fehlerhaft oder
verspätet läuft nicht vergessen danke
vielen Dank Herr Kollege Kurt Markus
kurt war das für Bündnis 90 die Grünen
und nun folgt René Springer erst der
Sprecher für Arbeit und Soziales der
afd-fraktion
[Applaus]
ja Präsident meine sehr geehrten Damen
und Herren liebe Gäste
wir debattieren über ein Gesetzentwurf
der Bundesregierung da geht es um eine
energiepreispauschale von 300 Euro für
Rentner die einmalig gezahlt werden soll
und es ist in diesem Fall durchaus
sinnvoll mal Betroffene zu Wort kommen
zu lassen und deswegen möchte ich aus
einem Brief zitieren einen Brief den
Frau Gruber Rentnerin aus München im
April an Frank-Walter Steinmeier die
Bundespräsidenten geschrieben hat und
mich hat sie dabei in Kopie gesetzt ich
zitiere Frau Gruber ich bin zutiefst
betroffen und sprachlos darüber dass wir
ganz normalen Rentner jetzt
Stromrechnungen akzeptieren müssen ohne
die geringste Chance oder Möglichkeit
einer Unterstützung
seit Jahren schon zahle ich als Mieterin
einer Zweiraumwohnung mit 41,5
Quadratmetern monatlich 160 Euro an
Strom das liegt an den uralten
Nachtspeicheröfen nun soll ich aufgrund
der geschrieb gestiegenen Preise eine
stromnachforderung Akzeptieren von 853
Euro alles zusammen muss sich in diesem
Jahr allein für Strom
2293 Euro zahlen die stromnachforderung
ist schon seit März 2022 fällig
und lässt mich nicht mehr ruhig schlafen
weil ich mir als fast 80-jährige
alleinlebende nicht mehr gesunde
Rentnerin kein Anwalt leisten kann und
mich die Sozialbehörden Quark gesetzlich
unterstützen können oder dürfen falle
ich überall durchs Rost und erkenne
dieser Staat hat die Relationen verloren
und uns Rentner vergessen
und in der Tat Frau Gruber hat recht es
wurde im Frühjahr von der
Bundesregierung den Parlament eine
Entlastungspaket beschlossen dass 300
Euro Entlastung für arbeitnehmervorsah
aber nichts für Rentner nichts für Frau
Gruber nichts für 20 Millionen in diesem
Land die in Rente sind und das Land
aufgebaut haben die wurden vergessen
nicht vergessen hat sich der Minister
selbst der mit seinen Bezügen von 25.000
Euro im Monat auch von der
energiepreispauschale profitiert hat
genauso wie der Kanzler mit seinen
30.000 Euro im Monat Frau Gruber hat
Recht diese Regierung hat jede Relation
verloren
ich möchte noch mal zu dem Brief
zurückkommen denn er geht ja noch weiter
der Staat und sämtliche Ämter und
Behörden sorgen und bemühen sich
ausschließlich nur noch um Flüchtlinge
Hartz IV-Bezieher Alleinerziehende
Schulabbrecher oder die Obdachlosen
denen seit vielen Monaten jeder
erdenkliche Hilfe zu Teil wird ganz zu
schweigen von ihren vielen
bemerkenswerten Ukraine Geldern und in
der Tat hat auch im Frühjahr die
Bundesregierung den sogenannten
rechtskreiswechsel beschlossen das heißt
das Ukrainer die jetzt nach Deutschland
kommen direkt ins Hartz-IV-System
integriert werden das heißt Anspruch
haben auf regeleistung und nicht nur das
auch Anspruch auf Miete haben und zwar
jede Miete jede Miete wird als
angemessen akzeptiert auch die 150
Quadratmeter Wohnung für 2500 Euro in
Charlottenburg und man kann davon
ausgehen dass eine Person bereits
mindestens Anspruch auf 1200 Euro hat
dem gegenüberstehen dem Statistischen
Bundesamt zu folge 5 Millionen in
Rentner die monatlich netto gerade mal
1000 Euro zur Verfügung haben sie haben
also eine Gruppe sie geben einer Gruppe
Geld Wohnung alles was dazu gehört einer
Gruppe die nie einen Cent in unserer
Sozialsystem eingezahlt hat und stellen
sie besser als Rentner die dieses Land
aufgebaut haben und eine Lebensleistung
erbracht haben einen größeren Spaltkeil
kann man nicht in diese Gesellschaft
treiben
[Applaus]
wissen sie auch wir sind für die
Unterstützung von Asylbewerbern aus der
Ukraine aber eben im Rahmen des
machtbaren und im Rahmen des üblichen
und das heißt einen Antrag stellen
Einzelfallprüfung Leistung nach dem
Asylbewerberleistungsgesetz und keine
Sonderprivilegien das kommt mit uns
nicht in Frage
und was nicht geht ist dass sie jede
Miete von Ukrainern übernehmen und
sämtliche heiz- und Betriebskosten
werden übernommen während Rentner mit
ihrem Gesetzentwurf mit 300 Euro
einmalig abgespeist werden die auch noch
versteuert werden müssen das ist alles
nur noch lächerlich und ehrlich gesagt
erinnert mich das an Anja Lena baerbock
die sagte die Ukraine ist ich stehe an
der Seite der Ukraine egal was meine
deutschen Wähler denken Herr Heil wenn
ihnen die Ukraine wichtiger sind als die
deutschen Rentner dann kann ich Ihnen
eins nahelegen treten sie zurück gehen
Sie in die Ukraine und lassen sich die
25.000 Euro dort von den Steuerzahler
zahlen
[Applaus]
René Springer war das für die
afd-fraktion hat sich hier noch einmal
über die vorherigen entlastungspakete
beschwert dass seiner Meinung nach dort
zu wenig Rentnerin und Rentner
berücksichtigt wurden Anja Schulz
spricht jetzt für die FDP sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren im Frühsommer haben
mich tatsächlich viele Nachrichten von
Rentnerinnen und Rentnern erreicht mit
der Frage ob wir sie beim
Entlastungspaket vergessen hatten meine
Antwort lautete immer nein das haben wir
nicht denn es gab eine Reihe von
Entlastung die jedem zugute kam der sich
in irgendeiner Weise motorisiert
fortbewegt hat der Stromrechnung zu
begleichen hatte und der Einkommensteuer
zahlen muss man wird sehr lange suchen
müssen um jemanden zu finden der nicht
in irgendeiner Form von unseren
entlastungspaketen profitiert hat und
genau dafür wurden sie auch konzipiert
trotzdem war die energiepreispauschale
omnipräsent und die anderen Maßnahmen
sind in ihrem Schatten regelrecht
verblasst auch die höchsten rennt auf
die höchste Rentenerhöhung seit
Jahrzehnten war das schnell vergessen es
stand dann immer nur die 300 Euro im
Raum und die Frage wer sie bekommt und
wer nicht das kann ich auch niemanden
verdenken dann das Maßnahmenpaket war
sehr groß und auch sehr kleinteilig und
an die Kollegen dort rechts von mir es
ist wichtig jetzt aktuell Einheit zu
demonstrieren anstatt Nährboden für Neid
und Missgunst zu schüren
inzwischen wir inzwischen wissen wir
dass nicht nur berufsbezogene Ausgaben
schwer zu stemmen sind auch die Erhöhung
der Energiekosten für den
durchschnittliches Einkommen sind
teilweise unzumutbar geworden und daher
ist es richtig dass wir jetzt
Rentnerinnen und Rentner
versorgungsbeziehende auch eine
energiepreispauschale zukommen lassen
die 300 Euro sind ein passendes und
notwendiges Mittel um die Menschen die
nächste Abschlagszahlung ein wenig
leichter zu machen uns allen ist aber
bewusst dass das nicht reicht und darum
haben wir es auch nicht bei diesen
Maßnahmen belassen rückwirkend für das
Jahr 2022 wurde beispielsweise der
Grundfreibetrag bei der Einkommensteuer
angehoben 2023 und 24 geht das Ganze
weiter und wir landen weil fast 11.000
Euro
durch die Abschaffung der kaltung
Progression passen wir die Eckwerte für
die Einkommensteuer ebenfalls an und
entgegen vieler Behauptungen entlastet
das nicht nur die Besserverdiener
sondern ebenso Menschen mit kleineren
und mittleren Einkommen denn in Relation
gesehen zu ihrer Steuerlast profitieren
Sie am meisten von der Anpassung
seit Jahren sinkt die Anzahl der
Menschen mit dem mittleren Einkommen und
die kalte Progression war mit Schuld
daran dass einkommensteuerzahler trotz
einer Lohnerhöhung im Zusammenspiel mit
der Inflation real weniger im Geldbeutel
hatten umso wichtiger ist es dass wir
das ganze jetzt abschaffen und die
Diskussion in der Zukunft nicht mehr
fortführen müssen
ich will betonen dass die Abschaffung
der kalten Progression nicht nur im
Kontext der entlastungspakete gesehen
werden darf sondern sie in Abschaffung
einer Ungerechtigkeit ist die wir schon
lange hatten
dennoch erfordern außergewöhnliche
Zeiten auch mehr Maßnahmen als nur
steuerliche Entlastung mit den drei
entlastungspaketen und einem Volumen von
knapp 90 Milliarden haben wir gezeigt
dass wir bereit dazu sind all das war
notwendig
dennoch weiß ich noch mal darauf hin
dass die einfachste Lösung um die
Bevölkerung zu entlasten bereits seit
Jahrzehnten existiert der Grundgedanke
muss da nicht erst von Experten in
irgendwelcher Form ermittelt werden
sondern ist so simpel wie logisch wenn
wir den Leuten weniger wegnehmen dann
haben sie auch mehr zur freien Verfügung
und dann müssen wir nicht in einer Robin
Hood Manier den Menschen in irgendeiner
Form Gelder wieder umverteilen lassen
wir den Menschen also mehr Netto vom
Brutto und diese Maßnahme verabschieden
wir nämlich mit in dem Paket ebenfalls
die diesem Grundgedanken entspricht
nämlich indem wir die midijob-grenze für
die Beschäftigung im Übergangsbereich ab
Januar auf 2000 Euro anheben in diesem
Übergangsbereich Zahlen
Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmer
verminderte Sozialversicherungsbeiträge
das ist sinnvoll denn steuerliche
Entlastung kommen gerade den
beschäftigen in diesem Bereich zugute es
wurde schon von 1,3 Milliarden
Entlastung in diesem Bereich gesprochen
ich will natürlich nicht unter den Tisch
fallen lassen dass diese 1,3 Milliarden
auch von irgendjemanden bezahlt werden
müssen und in diesem Übergangsbereich
ist es so dass Arbeitgeber und
Arbeitnehmer sich die Kosten nicht
paritätisch teilen sondern die Anteile
variieren je nach Höhe des Gehalts je
näher jemand an der minijob-grenze ist
desto höher auch der Anteil der
Sozialversicherungsbeiträge für den
Arbeitgeber das soll ab 2023 dann auch
2000 Euro ausgeweitet werden also diese
Entlastung Zahlen am Ende die
Arbeitgeber und auch die stehen gerade
nicht in einer Blütezeit die
Möglichkeiten für weitere Anpassungen
nach oben sind daher sehr ausgereizt und
wir sollten uns stattdessen mit der
Frage beschäftigen warum unsere
Sozialversicherungsbeiträge überhaupt zu
hoch sind und warum sie kontinuierlich
ansteigen lassen wir uns das Problem
also an der Wurzel packen und die
Symptome bekämpfen
vielen Dank Anja Schulz war das für die
FDP-Fraktion und für die Linksfraktion
wird nun im Matthias birkwald sprechen
ihr Sprecher für
alterssicherungspolitik und auch
Sprecher für Rentenpolitik seiner
Fraktion
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident meine Damen
und Herren verehrter Minister Hubertus
Heil ich hoffe wir sind uns einig
niemand soll Angst haben müssen im
Winter im kalten oder im Dunkeln zu
sitzen
leider ist die Realität eine andere
derzeit müssen beispielsweise 7,7
Millionen altersrentnerinnen und
Altersrentner von weniger als 1250 Euro
netto Gesamteinkommen im Monat leben das
sind 44 Prozent die aktuell unter der
eu-armutsschwelle liegen werte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen der Ampel
bekämpfen sie endlich wirksam die
Altersarmut
derzeit explodieren die
Lebensmittelpreise und die Energiepreise
gehen durch die Decke und was tun sie
für diese älteren Menschen die viel zu
wenig Geld im Portemonnaie haben ab
Januar sollen die Allerärmsten gerade
einmal 53 Euro mehr Grundsicherung im
Alter also Rentner hartz-
vorne und hinten nicht und die 290.000
Rentnerhaushalte die Wohngeld beziehen
erhalten einen Heizkostenzuschuss von
415 Euro einmalig und ebenfalls einmalig
wird es im Dezember für alle
Rentnerinnen und Rentner endlich eine
energiepreispauschale von 300 Euro geben
die meistens automatisch überwiesen
werden wird das ist gut so jeder Euro
hilft und das hatten wir linken schon im
Sommer gefordert
aber das kommt alles viel zu spät das
hat alles mit den realen
Kostensteigerungen nicht zu tun und es
ist willkürlich statt 53 Euro mehr
müssten es mindestens 200 Euro mehr sein
Liebe Koalition so geht es nicht es geht
auch anders
in Österreich erhalten menschliche
Rentner schon heute eine um 1166 Euro
höhere Durchschnittsrente als hiesige
Rentner und Rentnerinnen bekommen
immerhin
353 Euro mehr jeden Monat und dort in
Österreich wird die Inflation per Gesetz
komplett ausgeglichen und oft gibt es
noch etwas oben drauf in Österreich wird
die Rente im kommenden Jahr für hohe
Renten und 5,8 Prozent angehoben für
mittlere Renten gibt es 8,5% mehr und
die Mindestrente wird sogar um 10%
erhöht werden liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen der Ampel nehmen Sie sich ein
Beispiel an Österreich
auch hierzulande ist es Zeit für eine
außerordentliche einmalige
Rentenerhöhung um zehn Prozent dann wäre
das Rentenniveau endlich wieder bei
lebensstandardsichernden 53 Prozent das
würde Beschäftigte mit einem
Durchschnittslohn von 3.242 Euro und
ihre Chefs gerade einmal jeweils nur
knapp 36 Euro mehr an Rentenbeitrag
Kosten außerdem meine Damen und Herren
brauchen wir jetzt eine Gas- und
strompreisbremse denn sonst werden alle
ihre Einmalzahlungen und Rentenerhöhung
gnadenlos verpufft damit niemand im
Winter frieren muss brauchen wir die
Umverteilung von oben nach unten und
darum fordere ich Sie auf beteiligen sie
endlich die Superreichen und die
krisenprofiteure und profiteurinnen an
den Kosten ich danke Ihnen
Matthias birkwald war das und wenn man
sich die Zahlen anguckt dass 2021 rund
4,9 Millionen Rentnerinnen und Rentner
monatlich weniger als 1000 Euro
Nettoeinkommen zur Verfügung hatten dann
versteht man natürlich dass das Sorge
macht wie diese die Strom und Gaspreise
zahlen sollen Tanja machalet jetzt für
die SPD
Kollegen lieber Herr Bergwald wir werden
ja demnächst Gelegenheit haben über die
Fragen das Rentenniveaus und anderer
Dinge zu sprechen aber ich möchte auch
gerade bei dem Thema noch mal
konstatieren im Hinblick auf die Frage
die der Kollege Rosemann eben an den
Kollegen Straubinger gestellt hat ich
glaube man kann ja noch mal festhalten
die CDU hat keine Haltung zum
Renteneintrittsalter die CDU hat auch
keine Haltung zum Renten Niveau das noch
mal fürs Protokoll
wenn ich jetzt so das letzte Jahr Revue
passieren lasse wir sind ja jetzt alle
jetzt sozusagen ein Jahr im neuen
Bundestag
dann hätte ich mir glaube ich vor einem
Jahr noch nicht vorstellen können dass
ich jetzt hier heute stehe und zu diesem
Thema spreche denn vor einem Jahr haben
wir eigentlich alle gedacht wir machen
noch Corona zu Ende und können dann die
großen Themen die wir im
Koalitionsvertrag festgeschrieben haben
auf den Weg bringen und dann kam der 24
februar und hat die Dimensionen in
diesem Land verschoben und es war uns
dort damals schon klar dass es jetzt
darum geht den Zusammenhalt in der
Gesellschaft zu sichern und härten die
damit verbunden sind abzufedern und
seitdem haben wir als Ampel viele
notwendige Entlastungen auf den Weg
gebracht und umgesetzt und man muss das
glaube ich schon auch noch mal in
Erinnerung rufen was das alles ist ich
mache jetzt gar keine vollständige Liste
aber der Heizkostenzuschuss die 300 Euro
energiepreispauschale für die
Beschäftigten der Erhöhung des
Grundfreibetrages rückwirkend zum ersten
ersten und vielleicht lohnt da einfach
auch noch mal ein Blick auf die
Gehaltsabrechnung im Juli und im
September weil mein Eindruck ist das für
dass das gar nicht so in den Köpfen
hängen geblieben ist das ist diese 300
Euro schon gegeben hat die Erhöhung des
Kindergeldes des neuen euro-ticket und
und nicht zuletzt auch die Erhöhung des
Mindestlohns der jetzt zum ersten
Oktober in Kraft getreten ist
die höchst Rentenerhöhung seit 40 Jahren
im Westen die wir im die zum ersten Juli
in Kraft getreten ist und so weiter und
wir stehen jetzt hier bei der Umsetzung
des dritten entlastungspakets mit einem
Gesamtvolumen von 65 Milliarden Euro
dieses dritte Entlastungspaket und darin
enthalten eben auch endlich die
energiepreispauschale für die
Rentnerinnen und Rentner und ich halte
das auch für eine Frage der
Gerechtigkeit und wenn es nach mir
gegangen wäre hätten wir das durchaus
auch schon etwas früher auf den Weg
gebracht aber man muss festhalten wir
nehmen für die energiepreispauschale bei
den Rentnerinnen und Rentnern sechs
Milliarden Euro in die Hand und ich
denke dabei auch lieber Kollege birkwald
an die kleine Rentnerin die im
Einfamilienhaus bei mir im Ort um die
Ecke wohnt die sich Sorgen darüber macht
ob sie an Weihnachten ihr haushalten
kann und genau das ist unser Punkt dass
wir sagen wir wollen noch im Dezember
die
preispauschale auszahlen
unbürokratisch das ist uns sehr wichtig
pfändungsfrei keine Verrechnung mit
Sozialleistungen oder dem
grundrentenzuschlag und man kann uns ja
natürlich immer dafür kritisieren dass
wir das pauschal machen dass jeder die
300 Euro bekommt aber ganz ehrlich
lieber Herr Straubinger wenn sie sagen
sie kriegen das zweimal es steht ihnen
völlig frei das genauso zu machen wie es
viele Bürgerinnen und Bürger in diesem
Land tun die auch sagen es ist schön
dass ihr das macht ich brauche es nicht
ich spende es an die Tafel oder an eine
andere gemeinnützige Einrichtung das
steht ihnen völlig frei ich halte das
für ich halte das für eine gute Haltung
derjenigen die sagen ich bin nicht so
stark betroffen ich brauche das nicht
aber es steht wie gesagt jedem Fall ich
freue mich jedenfalls auf die Beratung
am Montag die Anhörung die Beratung in
der nächsten Woche und dass wir dann
eben auch zügig und schnell beschließen
und umsetzen und für diesen Moment
herzlichen Dank wir sehen uns nächste
Woche zum gleichen Thema wieder
vielen Dank Frau Kollegin tanja
marchalett hat hier noch einmal
aufgezählt verschiedene
Entlastungsmaßnahmen der Bundesregierung
hier in dieser ja Energiekrise in der
wir uns befinden Stefan Nacke spricht
jetzt für die Unionsfraktion Kolleginnen
und Kollegen mit dem vorliegenden
Gesetzesentwurf vermischt die Ampel
Dinge die nichts miteinander zu tun
haben sie betreiben mit der einmaligen
energiepreispauschale für Rentnerinnen
und Rentner Krisenpolitik und mit der
Anhebung der midijob-grenze
Ordnungspolitik die unabsehbare
Konsequenzen hat es ist nicht schwer zu
erkennen was hinter dieser unlogischen
Verquickung von Krisen und
Ordnungspolitik steht sie wollen dass
das eine Thema in der öffentlichen
Diskussion das andere überlagert sie
schieben der populären
energiepreispauschale ihre
midijob-reform einfach unter und
versuchen unbemerkt unseren Sozialstaat
umzubauen
aber schauen wir uns die
energiepreispauschale erstmal genauer an
um es gleich vorweg zu sagen wir sind
froh dass die Rentnerinnen und
Versorgungsempfänger endlich auch zu
ihrem Recht kommen die Union hat das
schon im Frühjahr des Jahres gefordert
damals wollte die Ampel sich die 6,4
Millionen Euro sparen und hat deshalb
nur den einkommensteuerpflichtigen
Erwerbstätigen eine pauschale gewährt
jetzt wird zu prüfen sein ob wirklich
alle Rentner mit dieser Pauschale
erreicht werden Stichwort
Bundesversorgungsgesetz gesetzliche
Unfallversicherung berufsständische
Versorgungswerke Renten aus privaten
Verträgen
ich habe im Mai auf meine drei
schriftlichen Fragen an die
ampelregierung warum die Rentnerinnen
und Rentner die Pauschale nicht bekommen
dreimal die gleiche Antwort erhalten
Zitat mit der energiepreispauschale
sollten nur diejenigen begünstigt werden
den typischerweise Fahrtkosten in
Zusammenhang mit ihrer Erwerbstätigkeit
entstehen die Pauschale sei ein
Ausgleich für gestiegene
wegeaufwendungen dafür haben sie damals
zu recht viel Kritik einstecken müssen
nun versuchen Sie diesen Fehler zu
beheben allerdings mit einer völlig
anderen Begründung jetzt sagen Sie in
der Gesetzesbegründung nicht mehr die
Fahrtkosten sein ausschlaggebend sondern
die hohen Lebenshaltungskosten der
Bürgerinnen und Bürger aufgrund der
Zitat Anhalt steigenden Energie- und
Nahrungsmittelpreise da frage ich mich
warum bekommen denn bei dieser
Begründung nur die Rentner und nicht
alle in der dieser Bevölkerung eine
erneuerte Pauschale
in meinen Augen ist gute Politik immer
auch eine Frage des richtigen Timings
das hat die Ampel leider nicht während
die Menschen sich fragen wie sie über
den Winter kommen sollen streiten sich
Herr Lindner und der Habeck öffentlich
und präsentieren uns über Wochen völlig
widersprüchliche Vorschläge ja wie denn
nun die Preise senken mit einem
gaspreisdeckel oder die Preise erhöhen
mit einer gasumlage und was macht
Kanzler Scholz nach der Bazooka holt er
nun zum 200 Millionen Milliarden Euro
doppelwumms aus und mit heißer Nadel
gestrickt wird eine Kommission
eingesetzt die ein tragfähiges Konzept
ausarbeiten soll sie hätte aber nicht
erst Ende September berufen werden
dürfen ihr schlechtes politisches Timing
ist schuld daran dass jetzt nur noch das
Prinzip Gießkanne davon war ja schon die
Rede wirklich
und ich sage Ihnen in aller Deutlichkeit
wer die Leidtragenden ihrer
unausgewogenen Politik sein werden
unsere Kinder denn die werden das
bezahlen müssen und das ist nicht
generationengerecht
nun zum zweiten Teil ihres auch mit
heißer Nadel gestrickten
Gesetzesentwurfs der Anhebung der
midijob-grenze von 1600 auf 2000 Euro
sie wollen die Beschäftigten um rund 1,3
Milliarden Euro entlasten machen aber
dafür unlaute Geschäfte zu Lasten
Dritter denn sie greifen 800 Millionen
Euro aus den Kassen der rentenkranken
und Pflegeversicherung und erhöhen
einseitig die Arbeitgeberbeiträge um 500
Millionen Euro damit verteilen sie Geld
dass ihnen nicht gehört
oberflächlich
betrachtet klingen Beitragsentlastung
für Beschäftigte erst einmal gut wenn
wir genauer hinschauen ist es aber nicht
so dass die geringeren
Rentenversicherungsbeiträge auch zu
geringeren Renten führen es entsteht
also eine Finanzierungslücke das
Äquivalenzprinzip also die Grundlage der
Rente als Versicherungs- und nicht als
Sozialleistung wird durch diese Anhebung
weiter ausgehöhlt die Differenz muss die
Solidargemeinschaft der Beitragszahler
tragen in sowieso schwierigen Zeiten die
Rentenversicherung weiter zu schwächen
ist verantwortungslos
ich habe den Eindruck dass sie
symbolpolitisch eine Gleichzeitigkeit
herstellen wollen auf der einen Seite
gleichen sie ihr Manko aus dem Frühjahr
aus indem sie die Rentnerinnen und
Versorgungsempfänger die Pauschale
zugestehen die sie ihnen bisher aus mit
fadenscheinigen Argumenten vorenthalten
haben auf der anderen Seite tun Sie so
als ob sie sich um die arbeitende
Bevölkerung bemühen und verändern
nachhaltig die Anreizstrukturen für mehr
Teilzeitarbeit obwohl wir doch das
Gegenteil brauchen viel mehr Menschen in
vollzeitverträgen
gute Politik wäre den Menschen klar zu
sagen es war ungerecht die Rentnerinnen
und Rentner im Frühjahr von der
energiepreispauschale auszuschließen
diesen Fehler beheben wir jetzt dafür
hätten Sie von uns Lob bekommen so wirkt
das was sie in diesem Gesetzentwurf
Vorhaben nicht wie gute Politik sondern
einfach nur wie Politik nach
Gutsherrenart vielen Dank
vielen Dank Herr Kollege Nacke
letzter Redner der Debatte ist der
Kollege Michael Gerdes SPD-Fraktion
herr Präsident meine Damen und Herren
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen Liebe
Minister Heil nachdem wir jetzt heute so
oft gehört haben was wir alles nicht
gemacht haben möchte ich Sie noch einmal
kurz daran erinnern dass wir erst vor
vier Monaten im Juni eine der größten
Rentenerhöhungen der letzten Jahrzehnte
beschlossen haben
wir haben im Westen und im Osten die
Rentnerinnen und Rentner gestärkt das
darf man nicht vergessen das war richtig
was sonst noch passiert ist hören sie
erstmal zu hören sie erstmal zu was
sonst noch passiert ist bzw was
passieren wird die Lage ändert sich
täglich ist jetzt gerade schon von
meinen Vorrednern und Vorrednern massiv
ausgeführt worden und ich denke wir
werden noch viel Gelegenheit haben uns
mit der aktuellen Politik die
auseinanderzusetzen aktuell werden wir
aber jetzt die Rentnerinnen und Rentner
und auch die versorgungsempfängerinnen
und Finger des Bundes im Dezember mit
einer energiepasspauschale von 300 Euro
unterstützen und das meine Damen und
Herren ist richtig darüber hinaus
erweitern wir die Verdienstgrenze für
MIDI und Minijobber wie die jobberinnen
und Jobber von 1600 auf 2000 Euro auch
das hilft meine Damen und Herren
insgesamt nimmt der Bund dafür 6,4
Milliarden Euro in die Hand gut so
Angesicht der angespannten Situation
möchte ich Sie aber auch auf die
Beobachtung vieler Tafeln und
sozialberatungsstellung verweisen dort
melden sich immer mehr Menschen aus
allen sozialen Schichten darunter
natürlich auch verstärkt Rentnerinnen
und Rentner aber auch Menschen die knapp
über dem Existenzminimum stehen und
diese Person brauchen zügig ein Zuschuss
und zwar unabhängig davon ob sie einen
Anspruch auf eine
alterserwerbsminderungs- oder
Hinterbliebenen Rente haben und nun auch
ein Wort zum Renteneintrittsalter weil
es manchmal gesagt worden ist die Rente
mit 67 hat nicht dazu geführt dass
Menschen die 67 Jahre auch im
Erwerbsleben bis zum Schluss erreicht
haben sondern ja dazu geführt dass viele
Menschen mit Abschlag vorzeitig in den
Ruhestand gegangen sind und heute in der
Situation sind dass sie mit ihrem mit
ihren Erwerbsleben nicht dafür sorgen
konnten dass sie heute altersgerecht
leben können und deshalb haben wir für
diese Gruppe auch keine Unterscheidung
unternommen und alle bekommen mit dem
Entlastungspaket eben diese 300 Euro
ausgezahlt und zwar unbürokratisch und
ohne ein Antrag stellen zu müssen und
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen allen die
jetzt sagen es reicht nicht antworte ich
stimmt natürlich werden wir als Ampel
auch weiter reagieren wenn wir merken
dass es zu sehr knirscht das ist doch
ganz klar und allen die jetzt sagen da
wird aber auch mir viel zu viel mit der
Gießkanne verteilt kann ich beruhigt
sagen die 300 Euro sind
sozialversicherungsfrei aber nicht
steuerfrei und insoweit profitieren nie
ihre Renten natürlich auch mehr als
üppige Pension das ist klar meine Damen
und Herren wir lassen die Rentnerinnen
und Rentner in der Krise nicht im Stich
und diejenigen die wenig verdienen auch
nicht das ist die Botschaft die uns in
den nächsten Monaten trägt davon wenig
fest überzeugt den sozialen Zusammenhang
Halt geben wir nicht auf und deshalb wir
reden hier nicht von einem schlechten
gewissengesetz Herr Straubinger wir
haben ein gutes Gewissen in diesem Sinne
Glück auf und danke schön
vielen Dank Herr Kollege Gerdes
damit schließe ich die Aussprache
interfraktionell Überweisung des
Gesetzentwurfs auf Drucksache 3.38 an
die Natascha auch für den Ausschüsse
vorgeschlagen gibt es weitere
überweisungsvorschläge des Seehund hörig
nicht dann verfahren wir wie
vorgeschlagen
ah bevor ich den Tagesordnungspunkt
so das sieht aus als würde Bundestags
viel zu präsident Wolfgang Kubicki hier
die Ergebnisse der Wahlen zu Gremien
bekommen haben
gebe ich Ihnen das Ergebnis der Wahlen
bekannt die wir abgehalten haben
zunächst die Wahl eines Mitglied des
Gremiums gemäß Paragraph 3 des
bundesschuldenwesengesetzes von den 736
Mitgliedern des Deutschen Bundestages am
640 ihre Stimme abgegeben mit ja haben
bestimmt 496 Abgeordnete mit Nein haben
bestimmt 107 Abgeordnete 337
Abgeordneten haben sich enthalten die
Abgeordnete Katrin michel hat die
erforderliche Mehrheit von mindestens
369 Stimmen erreicht sie ist gemäß
Paragraph 3 des
bundesschuldenwesengesetzes in das
Gremium gewählt herzlichen Glückwunsch
nun kommen wir zur Wahl der Mitglieder
des Gremiums gemäß Paragraph 5 des
Gesetzes für Finanzierung der Bundeswehr
und zur Errichtung eine Sondervermögens
Bundeswehr
von den 736 Mitgliedern des Hauses haben
640 ihre Stimmen abgegeben von den
abgegebenen Stimmen in vielen auch Dr
Michael espendiller 90 Stimmen mit ja
mit Nein 580 Stimmen bei 23 Enthaltungen
und neuen ungültigen Stimmen und auf die
Kollegen Dr Gesine Lötzsch
mit ja 366 stimmen mit Nein 225 Stimmen
bei 45 Stimmen
damit Scherben die Abgeordneten Dr
Michael espendiller und die Kollegin Dr
Gisel Lötsch die erforderliche Mehrheit
von 369 stimmen beide nicht erreicht
bei Frau Dr löt handelt sich um drei
Stimmen es ist mehrfach nach es ist
mehrfach nachgezählt worden das Ergebnis
ist wie gesagt überprüft worden insofern
steht das jetzt
wir kommen damit zum Tagesordnungspunkt
so das dürfte hier für Enttäuschung bei
der Linksfraktion sorgen Gesine lötz war
am 22 September schon einmal für dieses
Gremium vorgeschlagen worden da geht es
um die Bewirtschaftung des 100
Milliarden Euro schweren Sonderfonds und
das Gremium soll diese Bewirtschaftung
beratend begleiten jetzt kommen wir aber
zur einem Antrag der cdu/csu-fraktion
wie der Güterverkehr und die
Logistikbranche aus der Krise geführt
werden kann erste Rednerin ist Martina
Engelhardt Kopf
zur geplanten Erhöhung der Lkw-Maut
sowohl logistikverbände als auch
Unternehmerinnen und Unternehmer haben
die aktuelle Situation in der Praxis
geschildert kurzum ihnen steht das
Wasser bis zum Hals sie können keine
weiteren Belastungen mehr gebrauchen die
Kosten für Kraftstoffe sind explodiert
ebenfalls schwierig und preissteigernd
AdBlue natürlich gibt es zu Recht von
Seiten Beschäftigten Lohnforderungen die
lohn-preisspirale setzt ein für
Unternehmer die auf LNG umgerüstet haben
sie das ganz düster aus im Gegensatz zu
Dieselfahrzeugen können hier die
Kostensteigerungen auf ebenfalls 600 bis
800 Prozent mehr nicht weitergegeben
werden sie stehen vor großen Verlusten
einige kurz vor der Insolvenz und die
Fahrzeuge stehen auf den Betriebshöfen
Unternehmerinnen und Unternehmer
Verbände aber auch wir als
Unionsfraktion weisenzeit Beginn des
Jahres auf die katastrophalen
Auswirkungen der Preisexplosion beim LNG
hin aber auch auf die Energiekrise auf
die gestiegenen Dieselkosten die
Bundesregierung wurde immer wieder zum
Handeln aufgefordert wir hatten
zahlreiche Anträge was es passiert
nichts es passiert nichts es gibt
Hilferufe es gibt Gespräche in
Ministerien es gibt runde Tische es gibt
Aufforderungen von unserer Seite das
zieht sich durch ihre Regierung es
passiert einfach nichts ich möchte an
dieser Stelle insbesondere den
Mittelstand noch einmal herausstellen
den Menschen den Betrieben den
Unternehmen steht das Wasser bis zum
Haus
um es ganz klar zu sagen am Beispiel von
Ellen Chi noch einmal das sind
Unternehmerinnen und Unternehmer die
bewusst auf klimafreundlichere
Technologien gesetzt haben die
investiert haben und das hat auch etwas
mit Vertrauensschutz zu tun aber auch
mit Vertrauensschutz ist das bei dieser
Bundesregierung nicht weit her ich
erinnere mich sehr gut an den
Schlamassel bei den KfW Förderprogrammen
so zerstören sie auch Vertrauen in die
Politik in unser demokratisches System
daher unser Appell bei den
entlastungspaketen schaffen sie endlich
auch einen LG Rettungsschirm für die
Logistikbranche lassen Sie nicht zu dass
diese Unternehmerinnen und Unternehmer
jetzt in Insolvenz gehen die
Sachverständigen aus der
güterkraftverkehrsbranche waren sich
gestern bei der öffentlichen Anhörung
auch einig die geplante mautserhöhung ab
dem kommenden Jahr kommt zur absoluten
Unzeit ich habe einige Probleme
aufgezeigt drohende Rezession Krise zur
jetzigen Zeit ein völlig falsches Signal
sie treiben damit nicht nur die
Inflation an diese Erhöhung entfaltet
auch keine Lenkungswirkung die Kosten
werden einfach an Verbraucherinnen und
Verbraucher weitergegeben oder aber die
Unternehmen die sowieso schon gebeutelt
sind bleiben auf ihnen sitzen dabei wäre
es sogar möglich die Maut auch zum
Jahresbeginn zu senken und nur die
Infrastrukturkosten beispielsweise
herauszugreifen so könnten wir sogar
entlasten und in einem größeren im
nächsten Jahr gegen Ende des Jahres ein
Gesamtpaket vorlegen die geplante
co2-differenzierung mit einbeziehen und
hier auch für Entlastungen sorgen indem
wir uns das Ganze im Gesamtpaket auch
noch mal anschauen also deshalb mein
dringender Appell verschieben Sie diese
mautserhöhung und legen Sie dann gegen
Ende des kommenden Jahres einen
vernünftigen Vorschlag vor ein weiterer
Punkt ist die
finanzierungskreislauf der Straße auch
der soll aufgeweicht werden da steht in
ihrem Koalitionsvertrag und ist dann
weiterer Schlag in das Gesicht der
promifahrer der Logistik und
Güterverkehrsunternehmen deshalb ganz
dringend unterstützen Sie unseren Antrag
lassen Sie uns einen Schritt aus der
Krise gemeinsam mit den Unternehmerinnen
und Unternehmer machen denn sie sind
systemrelevant für uns für unser ganzes
Land herzlichen Dank vielen Dank Frau
Kollege Ehler
nächster Redner ist der Kollege Udo
Schiffner SPD-Fraktion
[Applaus]
Vorsitz
Ende Deutschen Bundestag
herr Präsident meine sehr geehrten Damen
und Herren liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
Güterverkehrs und Logistikbranche aus
der Krise führen selbstverständlich ist
das ein Thema und selbstverständlich
würde ich gerne sogar jede Woche über
dieses Thema diskutieren weil man
natürlich auch Antworten braucht und als
Wirtschaftsfaktor und Arbeitsplatz haben
gerade Transport und Logistik enorme
Relevanz das wissen wir
Logistikketten haben davon ab und
ich begrüße sehr wenn man gerne täglich
mehrmals uns bewusst machen was es heißt
wenn Unternehmen eine Gerade
Logistikketten nicht mehr
aufrechterhalten können
ich begrüße dass die tatsächlichen
Belastungen der kleinen und
mittelständischen Unternehmen und
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter
öffentlich diskutiert werden wir nach
Lösungen suchen und schon vor der
Pandemie hatten wir eine Situation
vor Krieg und energiekräfte Krise die
Betriebe stark belasteten und die
Betriebe auch teilweise nicht mehr
Stimmen konnten und da brauchen wir
Lösungen das sage ich auch durchaus aus
Sicht der Sozialdemokratie aber Lösungen
zu dem Thema Frau Kollegin die sie hier
angesprochen haben stehen in ihrem
Antrag ja nicht
sondern das waren hier ihre Worte die
ich zwar vernehme die man diskutieren
kann aber ihr Antrag der übrigens erst
am späten Dienstagabend bei der
Bedeutung dieses Themas eingegangen ist
zeigt wenig Substanz sondern er zeigt
viel mehr
dass man dass man hier schön und das
muss ich anerkennen hier die einzelnen
Punkten noch mal aufführt aber keine
Lösungsansätze und deshalb ist es
wichtig dass wir unsere Reihe fortsetzen
die wir fraktionsübergreifend darum
Ausschuss aufgelegt haben mit den
Verbänden zu reden mit den Betroffenen
zu reden und Lösungen anzubieten und
dazu lade ich Sie ein auch in den
nächsten Wochen gemeinsam mit den
Fraktionen der Koalition zu arbeiten und
sie fordern beispielsweise die
beschleunigte Instandsetzung der
inverkehrsinfrast Natur den Bau von
lkw-parkplätzen von Autohöfen und die
Umsetzung des
Bundesverkehrswegeplanes nichts anderes
haben wir in unserem Koalitionsvertrag
vielen Dank für Ihre Zustimmung auch
wenn Sie den Alter an der Stelle auch
nicht mit unterschreiben konnten meine
Damen und Herren der Union sie wollen
einen runden Tisch zu Fahrermangel des
Bundesministeriums ja runde Tische sind
ja immer gut sie haben aber doch
bitteschön auch zur Kenntnis zu nehmen
dass dort ein Gipfel stattgefunden hat
mit vielen vielen Vertretern
mehr als ein Verbände Treffen zu diesem
Thema und ich bin mir sicher dass
Ministerium wird auch da weiter aufbauen
und die Themen aufnehmen und wir werden
auch davon bin ich überzeugt schon in
Maßnahmen einleiten gemeinsam mit dem
Betroffenen die zeigen wie wichtig uns
die Logistikbranche ist und wie wichtig
es ist uns auch ist hier eine
zukunftsfähige
Logistikbranche zu haben mit sozialen
Bedingungen guter Bezahlung für
Fahrerinnen und Fahrer nur so werden wir
unsere logistiketten auf Dauer weiter
erhalten können wir wissen die
Unternehmen brauchen unsere
Unterstützung und auch die Fahrerinnen
und Fahrer brauchen unsere Unterstützung
und da werden wir gerne mit Ihnen
gemeinsam die was bisher gemacht haben
auch Arbeiten ihr Antrag wird ja
Gegenstand weiter Erwartungen sein kann
auch nach wie vor eine gute Grundlage
mit vielen Schlagworten sein nur der
Knochen alleine reicht nicht satt wird
man nur wenn auch an diesem Knochen
letztlich Fleisch ist und das ist unsere
Aufgabe sinnbildlich auch für die
Logistikbranche hier aktiv zu werden und
die doch tätigen Menschen im Übrigen
nicht durfte dies als letzter Satz weil
sie so die neuen
Koalitionäre anprangern mal daran
erinnern ich durfte viele Jahre auch mit
ihnen in einer Koalition sitzen
aber ich muss ehrlich sagen an vielen
Stellen haben wir zusammen viel erreicht
das muss man ehrlich sagen
aber
ich sage auch
dass ich nicht mehr den Eindruck habe
sondern froh bin dass wir in dieser
Koalition mehr Herzblut für die Logistik
an den Tag legen als das bisher der Fall
war unter der alten Leitung des
Ministeriums vielen Dank für Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit
vielen Dank Herr Kollege Schiffner ja
gab es jetzt zum Schluss doch einige
Reaktionen hier positiv so wie negativ
auf die Bemerkung von Udo schiefner René
Bochmann spricht nun als nächstes er
sitzt für die afd-fraktion im
Verkehrsausschuss
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident sehr
geehrte Kollegen Liebe Landsleute auf
den Tribünen und an dem Bildschirm zur
Beratung steht der Antrag cdu/csu
Güterverkehr und Logistikbranche aus der
Krise führen wobei die CDU CSU 12 Jahre
Zeit gehabt hätte die komplette
Verkehrsinfrastruktur für solche
Situationen vorzubereiten hätten die
damaligen Regierungsverantwortlichen
Teile dieser Wirtschaftsbereiche
konsequent unterhalten erneuert und
ausgebaut könnten wir in dieser Krise
jetzt auf die für uns lebenswichtigen
Transportwege verlassen haben ihre
Minister Ramsauer Schmidt Dobrindt und
scheuer die Signale aus der Wirtschaft
bewusst nicht ernst genommen oder
fahrlässig ignoriert
dabei erinnere ich auch an die 100
Millionen Euro welche dem Steuerzahler
durch das pkw-mautdesaster verloren ging
genau dies ist ihr Vermächtnis
der ukraine-krieg verbunden mit den
Russland Sanktionen verstärken diese
katastrophalen Zustand jetzt um ein
Vielfaches nicht nur der Gaspreis
sondern auch die Preise anderer
Rohstoffe explodieren schlagartig und
treiben nun Reparatur und Baukosten in
die Höhe die daraus resultierende
Inflation führt neben zahlreichen
Unternehmen in fast jeder Branche auch
viele noch gutbürgerliche Haushalte
damit zwangsläufig in Existenznot sehr
geehrte Kollegen nochmal zwei
Erinnerungen
Kommunikations- und
Verkehrsinfrastruktur sind das Skelett
eines jeden Staates und stellen damit
alle Lebensbereiche sicher Straße
Schiene Wasser und Luft es fehlt an
Berufskraftfahrern an Lokführern
Personal in der Seelen Binnenschifffahrt
in der Flugabfertigung und das nicht
erst seit Beginn des ukrainekrieges
sondern bereits seit ihrer letzten
Amtszeit in Regierungsverantwortung
liebe Kollegen der CDU
denn auch vor der corona-pandemie und
vor dem ukrainekrieg lagen bereits
zahlreiche Schiffe vor Helgoland und
warteten wochenlang auf ihre Abfertigung
in deutschen Sehhilfen gab es marode
Schleusen in der Binnenschifffahrt
Beschäftigte uns die Elbvertiefung die
ständig Probleme mit nachrutschenden
Schlick verursacht und es gab bereits
tausende dringend reparaturbedürftige
Straßenbrücken auf diese bisherige
Problemanalyse folgen nun unsere
Lösungsvorschläge 1 alle
russland-sanktionen sofort beenden
zweitens bisher vertraglich vereinbarten
Gase und Öllieferungen aus Russland
wieder nutzen drittens lassen Sie mich
bitte Ausreden alle derzeit noch verfügt
zur Verfügung stehenden reaktivierbaren
Kern und Kohlekraftwerke zur
energiesicherung einbinden
viertens CO2-Abgabe komplett abschaffen
fünftens keine Mauterhöhung in der
Krisensituation
sechstens Planungsverfahren zur
Sanierung und zum Neubau von
Verkehrsinfrastruktur beschleunigen um
den Wirtschaftsstandort auch unseren
Transport-
drittens Förderung der dringend
benötigten Auto Ausbildungsberufe
Kraftfahrer hochsee- und
Binnenschifffahrt sowie Lager und
logistikfachkräfte achtens
Mehrwertsteuer zur Entlastung der Bürger
langfristig auf 7% senken sehr geehrte
Kollegen ich fordere Sie hiermit
ausdrücklich auf unsere Bürger und denen
noch sicheren Wirtschaftsstandort
Deutschland vor drohenden Schaden zu
bewahren indem sie diesem Antrag
ebenfalls zustimmen sie alle haben es in
der Hand und müssen es nur wollen wir
stimmen diesem Antrag zu und ich danke
für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
vielen Dank Herr Kollege Bachmann
[Applaus]
als nächster Redner das Wort der Kollege
Matthias Gastel Bündnis 90
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident liebe
Kolleginnen liebe Kollegen es geht um
die Krise in der Logistik und ja
natürlich gibt es diese Krise und ich
kann sagen und feststellen mit Blick in
den Koalitionsvertrag der Ampel aber
auch mit dem was wir bereits begonnen
haben umzusetzen wir reagieren auf die
Krise was aber ihren Antrag von der
cdu/csu-fraktion angeht da muss man
einfach mal sagen sie verengen mal
wieder eine Thematik ganz ganz massiv es
gibt bei Ihnen zum Beispiel keine
Klimakrise ganz offensichtlich taucht
hier überhaupt nicht auf und das sind
massive Herausforderungen den wir uns
hier stellen müssen sie sind hier total
LKW fixiert unterwegs natürlich der LKW
hat einen Anteil von 74 Prozent im
Bereich des Güterverkehrs niemand kann
ihn niemand will ihn ausblenden aber es
gibt eben auch noch andere Dinge es gibt
beispielsweise eine Bahn die nicht
leistungsfähig genug ist die
Lieferketten
stärker zu unterstützen aufrecht zu
erhalten was auch damit zu tun hat dass
sie dieses dass sie das System Schiene
über viele Jahre schlicht und ergreifen
kaputt gespart haben sie sind dafür
mitverantwortlich dass so viel über die
Straße gehen muss und zu wenig über die
Schiene gehen kann weil da nicht die
Leistungsfähigkeit vorhanden ist und
nicht die Zuverlässigkeit entsprechend
möglich ist und wenn Sie jetzt und wenn
Sie jetzt hier aus der Unionsfraktion
dazwischen rufen dann nenne ich ihn
jetzt mal drei Namen drei Namen Ramsauer
Dobrindt und scheuer ich an ihrer Stelle
wenn nicht bei ihrer Fraktion wäre ich
würde mich bei jeder verkehrsdiskussion
im Bundestag in den tiefsten Löchern des
Reichstagsgebäudes vor kriechen bei dem
was sie alles versäumt haben an
notwendigen Entscheidungen anstatt hier
mit solchen Anträgen zu kommen
wir diskutieren hier Versäumnisse die
sie haben die sie zu verantworten haben
mit 3 csu-verkehrsminister das war
einfach zu viel für das ganze System
Straße denken Sie mal an die Brücken die
bröckeln für das System Schiene das
nicht leistungsfähig genug ist und jetzt
rufen Sie auch noch dazwischen wenn ich
darauf hinweist
so in ihrem Antrag in ihrem Antrag
fordern Sie ein am
Bundesverkehrswegeplan festzuhalten was
sie was sie leider völlig versäumen und
ignorieren ist dass sie damals vor
Jahren als der aufgestellt wurde einfach
eine Auflistung von gewünschten
Projekten gemacht haben sie haben weder
priorisiert sie haben weder finanziert
sie haben nicht gesagt in welcher
Reihenfolge mit welchen
Planungskapazitäten was funktionieren
soll sie haben keine Umwelt und keine
verlagerungsziele auf die Schiene
verfolgt und das ist jetzt das womit wir
zu tun haben wir haben als
Ampelkoalition vereinbart dass wir die
Projekte priorisieren wollen wir haben
vereinbart dass wir sie neu aufstellen
wollen wir haben einen Dialogprozess
vereinbart um einen Konsens über die
Infrastrukturentwicklung in Deutschland
herbeizuführen das sind nämlich die
Dinge die nicht gemacht wurden die aber
notwendig sind und wir werden darauf
gucken müssen dass wir wirklich die
Projekte voranbringen die in Sinn die
notwendig sind die aber auch
finanzierbar sind und die Klimaziele
nicht im Wege stehen das ist unsere
Aufgabe die haben wir auch entsprechend
vereinbart im Vertrag sie fordern
Infrastrukturprojekte zu beschleunigen
sie haben in der letzten Legislatur
mehrere beschleunigungsgesetze
beschlossen die sich jetzt aber als
weitgehend wirkungslos erweisen wir sind
dabei zu arbeiten in einer
beschleunigungskommission für die
Schiene die wird noch im Oktober ihre
Ergebnisse vorlegen und ich bin da sehr
optimistisch dass wir genau die Dinge
dann auch entsprechend präsentieren mit
denen wir deutlich schneller vorankommen
gerade beim Ausbau der Schienenwege die
eben über Jahre man muss schon fast
sagen über Jahrzehnte entsprechend
versäumt sind
und wir binden hier auch das scheint
ihnen ja zumindest rhetorisch hier im
Antrag wichtig zu sein wir binden auch
die Branche eng ein wir haben
Unternehmen dabei wir haben
Umweltverbände dabei die auch sich daran
beteiligen die entsprechenden Maßnahmen
um schneller bei der Infrastruktur
voranzukommen mit auszuarbeiten so sie
schreiben sie wollen die
Nutzerfinanzierung ausbauen gleichzeitig
schreiben Sie aber auch keine Ausweitung
der Lkw-Maut wie soll man denn das
Zusammenbringen das eine passt nicht zum
anderen und deswegen ist es gut und
richtig dass wir an der
Weiterentwicklung der Lkw-Maut arbeiten
wir müssen es von Gesetzeswegen wir
wollen es aber auch weil eben die
Lkw-Maut zusätzliche Aufgaben und
Funktionen erfüllen muss sie muss zum
einen die Finanzierung der Infrastruktur
ermöglichen sie muss aber zum anderen
auch eine Lenkungsfunktion haben damit
mehr Güter auf die Schiene wandern
können das Klimaziele erreichbar sind
und genau diese Dinge haben wir im
Koalitionsvertrag vereinbart es liegt
jetzt im Gesetzentwurf vor da wird
sicherlich noch mal darüber geredet
werden müssen wie das sich
weiterentwickelt im parlamentarisch aber
wir sind da auf jeden Fall dran und auf
einem guten Weg sie fordern einen runden
Tisch ja wenn man nicht mehr weiter weiß
dann gründet man sie kennen den Spruch
aber wir sind im ständigen Dialog auch
beispielsweise bei AdBlue die Thematik
haben sie angesprochen in ihrem Antrag
da sind wir aber längst in einem
intensiven Austausch mit den Herstellern
mit der Industrie mit den Verbänden und
wir werden ganz schnell reagieren wenn
es tatsächlich Engpässe geben sollte
denn es ist völlig klar dass die
Lieferketten funktionieren müssen und da
sind wir immer im Gespräch mit den
entsprechenden Stellen also im Fazit wir
führen die Dialoge die wir die führen
wollen die notwendig sind und wir machen
das gerne wir machen das überzeugt es
ist viel in der Pipeline und viel auch
schon bereits in der Umsetzung übrigens
auch in Sachen Ladeinfrastruktur für
elektrische LKW die notwendig sind und
sie für die Zukunft sollten Sie noch mal
Anträge stellen denken sie dann auch an
die Schiene denken Sie an den
Klimaschutz denken Sie an die
Verlagerung wenn sie nicht dran denken
wir tun es vielen Dank
Matthias Gastl war das für Bündnis 90
die Grünen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen einen
schönen guten Nachmittag von meiner
Seite auch an die Besucherinnen und
Besucher auf den Tribünen und wir führen
die Debatte fort mit dem nächsten Redner
Fraktion DIE LINKE Thomas Lutze
frau Präsidentin sehr geehrte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen die Speditionen
in unserem Land und deren Personal waren
durch die corona-pandemie und sind durch
die aktuelle Energiekrise extrem stark
betroffen diese Einschätzung teilen wir
mit der antragstellenden Fraktion ob es
allerdings ausreicht alleine diesen Teil
des gütersverkehr Lösungen zu entwickeln
ist umstritten und letztendlich bleibt
es bei Symptombekämpfung die Ursachen
der verkehrspolitischen Misere löst man
indem man mit den Vorschlägen der Union
nicht auch nicht für die Spedition
drei Punkte 1 der Güter Fernverkehr
gehört zu 80 bis 90 Prozent auf die
Schiene wir brauchen da nicht mehr
Parkplätze und Rasthöfe LKWs wir
brauchen mehr umlademöglichkeiten für
LKWs auf die Schiene wir brauchen
wir brauchen auch einen Schienensystem
das überhaupt genügend Kapazität für
diesen Güterverkehr hat wenn auf
demselben Gleis heute ICEs mit 250 km/h
Regionalexpress zum Beispiel mit 140
km/h und der Güterzug mit 100 km/h
unterwegs ist dann muss doch einen klar
sein dass es hier Konflikte gibt können
wir dann noch Baustellen langsam
fahrstellen und Beschränkungen bei der
axlast hinzu dann verstehe ich jedes
Unternehmen dass seine Produkte lieber
über die Straße versendet als über die
Schiene hier wurde aber seit Jahren der
Kollege Gastel hat gesagt seit den 80er
Jahren massiv zurückgebaut und der
LKW-Verkehr als die einzige Lösung
dargestellt eine fatale Fehlentwicklung
wie ich meine
zweitens eine weitere Lösung der Misere
wäre eine konsequente Förderung
regionale Wirtschaftskreisläufe es ist
doch ein Unding das Obst und Gemüse aus
der Region in der Regel teurer ist als
die gleichen Produkte die über hunderte
Kilometer herangefahren werden aber auf
auch aber selbst eine auf regionale
Produkte ausgelegte Wirtschafts- und
Strukturpolitik braucht eine liefer- und
speditionsverkehr der leistungsfähig ist
hier benötigen wir tatsächlich
Verbesserung für die Speditionen und vor
allen Dingen Kriteren Personal drittes
Stichwort just in time seit zwei
Jahrzehnten haben viele
Industrieunternehmen ihres ist dieses
System eingeführt sie sparen damit sich
die eigene teure Lage Haltung und
bestellen die Ware und lassen die LKWs
so lange vor dem Berg Tor warten bis die
Ladung direkt am Fließband gebraucht
wird in aller Regel sind auch hier die
kleine Spediteure und die Fahrerin die
Leidtragenden da das zu Ihren Lasten
geht ja Lagerhaltung kostet Geld aber in
dem waren alles flexibler gestalten
wollen wurden diese Kosten vom
Unternehmen der eigentlich Auftraggeber
ist an die Öffentlichkeit
beziehungsweise an die Speditionen
getragen liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
im Bereich des Güterverkehrs gibt es
ganz viele Baustellen besser gesagt es
ist eine einzige Baustelle unser System
des Warentransports muss deswegen
grundlegend verändert werden auf den
Straßen aber ebenso auf den Schienen und
auf dem Wasserstraßen vielen Dank und
Glück auf
Thomas Lutze war das für die
Linksfraktion und nun hören wir dem
parlamentarischen Staatssekretär beim
Bundesminister für digitales und Verkehr
Oliver luxic
ja frau Präsidentin liebe Kollegen
Kollegen ich freue mich dass wir über
Logistik uns unterhalten das ist ein
ganz zentraler Sektor es geht um die
Lebensadern der Wirtschaft und ja die
Logistikketten sind angespannt weil wir
multiple Krisen haben Corona
Lieferketten Probleme Energie
Fahrermangel aber klar ist doch die
Lieferketten sind angespannt aber sie
halten und das ist die Kernbotschaft und
da fällt ihm in ihrem Antrag relativ
wenig zu einem der ist in weiten Teilen
unterkomplexes haben im Kollegen
angesprochen wir haben ja Häfen Schiene
Luftverkehr sie reden nur vom LKW ich
erkenne da die Handschrift eines
Verbandes sehr stark aber jetzt aus
einem Verband was zu übernehmen ist ein
bisschen weniger eine Sammelsurium an
Spiegelstrichen und kein Konzept Ludwig
Erhard wird sich da wird da auch mal ein
paar Fragezeichen machen wenn er das
liest ja
sie fordern runde Tische ich kann Ihnen
sagen wir sind im wöchentlichen
Austausch mit der Branche ich höre da
eigentlich auch wenig Beschwerden was
unsere Arbeit angeht im Gegenteil die
fühlen sich da gut aufgehoben liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen was die
Infrastruktur angeht hat es ja der
Kollege Gastl gesagt die ist auch da
gibt es Versäumnisse die wir jetzt
beseitigen müssen sei es bei der Schiene
Elektrifizierung und ausbaubeschleunigen
aber auch bei der Straße wo wir in der
Tat priorisieren müssen und deswegen
switchen wir eben um wir haben
vorgefunden 4.000 kaputte Brücken
deswegen gibt es jetzt den Fokus auf das
Brücken modernisierungsnetz wir werden
die Zahl der zu sanierenden Brücken
erhöhen das ist auch wichtig für die
Logistik in Deutschland wir müssen das
Aufräumen was wir vorgefunden haben
leider keinen planungsvorrat nur kaputte
Brücken wir gehen das jetzt an
sie haben angesprochen die
lkw-stellplätze das ist unstrittig auch
die bauen wir aus 700 Millionen Euro
nicht nur an Bundesfernstraßen sondern
auch an Autohöfen das ist neu das klappt
gut und kommt gut unterwegs und ja in
der Tat also wenn sie schon sich nur von
LKWs reden da gibt es in der Tat die
Herausforderung der
Kraftstoffpreise deswegen gab es eben
kurzfristig den Tankrabatt oder das kann
ja nicht die Dauerlösung sein und
deswegen haben wir über das Statistische
Bundesamt das Kartellamt eingeführt das
wöchentlich die Preise veröffentlicht
werden damit die Unternehmen die in der
Regel einen Diesel Floater haben die
Preise weitergeben können das ist
Marktwirtschaft das funktioniert das
haben wir gemacht und das läuft auch gut
CO2-Abgabe haben sie nicht erwähnt aber
die wird ja ausgesetzt das ist auch
glaube ich in der jetzigen Lage
angemessen und lassen Sie uns jetzt zur
Maut kommen weil ich da etwas überrascht
bin dass sie einen komplexes Regelwerk
da etwas unterkomplex darstellen wir
haben zum einen die eurovignetten
Richtlinie die Mitgliedstaaten aufgibt
Änderungen umzusetzen und zum anderen
das Bundesfernstraßen Maut
Änderungsgesetz das letzte hat die große
Koalition mit Verkehrsminister scheuer
gemacht und das Gesetz sieht vor dass
wir das Wegekosten Gutachten der letzten
fünf Jahre mit einem Stichtag ersten 23
umsetzen und deswegen es wurde eben ein
Aspekt gewählt die Infrastrukturkosten
sie haben aber eben vergessen die
Ansetzung von Lärm und Umweltkosten also
die Internalisierung externer Effekt
auch die ist rechtlich notwendig und
deswegen möchte ich sie mal an eine
einfache Tatsache erinnern bei der
Wissen selektive Wahrnehmung ist bei so
Anhörung sie haben den Experten Herrn
Schulz benannt weil er früher
Staatssekretär im unionsgeführten
Ministerium und ihr benannter Experte
bei der tollkollekt wurde auch mal
Mister Mord genannt der hat klar gesagt
es ist rechtlich notwendig um eine
rechtssichere Maut zum ersten ersten 23
zu haben um zu verhindern dass es
weitere Klagen und Einnahmeausfälle gibt
dass wir das so umsetzen insofern hören
Sie auf die Experten die sie selber
vorgeschlagen haben
ja liebe Kollegen Kollegen der
lng-bereich den sprechen Sie an in der
Tat das Argument der Planungssicherheit
ist ein Argument man kann jetzt im
Nachhinein fragen ob so schlau war dass
sie die mautausnahme in dem Aspekt so
geschaffen haben jetzt haben die
Unternehmen sich das angeschafft
deswegen sind wir auch mit denen im
Austausch um mir Lösung finden auch mit
dem bmwk im Austausch da gibt es jetzt
auch Programme für energieintensive
Kleinunternehmen muss man schauen ob man
dort das regeln kann aber es
entscheidend ist die EU-Kommission
wollte ihre Ausnahme ja nie die will ja
sogar hat er ein
Vertragsverletzungsverfahren geht die
Bundesrepublik angekündigt das haben sie
hier unterschlagen und abgesehen von
Weltmarktpreis LNG sie fordern ja den an
den Diesel zu gucken also das ist
koppeln das ist ja relativ kompliziert
da machen sie einen halben Satz da
müssen wir bitte erklären mit Zahlen
Daten und Fakten wie das gehen soll also
einfach eine Forderung von Verbänden
kopieren ist glaube ich ein bisschen
dünn klar ist wir wollen auch hier den
ausländischen Unternehmern helfen aber
wenn sie fordern den lng-preis an den
Diesel zu koppeln erklären sie mal bitte
wie das geht das kann ich aus ihrem
Antrag nicht rauslesen
und da sie immer viel den adblue-mangel
beschwören was übrigens auch zu
Hamsterkäufen führt und die Lage eher
erschwert als verbessert lassen Sie mich
klar sagen wir haben das gerade auch mit
den National contact point der EU
diskutiert und da gibt es eine
Entspannung der Lage erfreulicherweise
wenn wir drei große Produzenten in
Deutschland die haben ja ein
funktionierenden europäischen
Binnenmarkt Staatssekretär Kellner ist
auch hier im ständigen Austausch wir
sind es auch und es ist hier gelungen
dass durch die gaspreisbremse auch in
Piesteritz wieder produziert wird also
es gibt weder in Europa noch eine
mangelage noch in Deutschland die gute
Nachricht ist die Versorgung mit AdBlue
ist erstmal gesichert insofern ist Ihr
Antrag auch an der Stelle nicht mehr
aktuell und zutreffend
wo es in der Tat viel zu tun gibt ist
der Fahrermangel auch da steht zwei drei
dünne Sätze drin das sollten wir glaube
ich alle nicht so gerieren dass die
Politik das Problem alleine lösen kann
wir haben allgemeinen Fachkräftemangel
und in erster Linie gute
Arbeitsbedingungen gute Löhne das ist
nicht so einfach deswegen arbeiten wir
daran setzen hier auf Einwanderung
Anerkennung von Führerscheinen das ist
glaube ich einer der wichtigen Aspekte
also sie sehen wir sind an den Themen
dran die Logistik die kennen sind
angespannt aber funktionieren in dem
Sinne bedanke ich mich für
Aufmerksamkeit hoffe es kommen in den
laufenden waren noch bessere Vorschläge
wenn es welche gibt nehmen wir die gerne
auf vielen Dank
Oliver luxic fordert hier weitere
Erklärungen zu diesem Antrag der
Unionsfraktion die könnte der nächste
Redner liefern Christoph bloß ist für
die Unionsfraktion Mitglied im
Verkehrsausschuss
frau Präsidentin verehrte Kolleginnen
und Kollegen zunächst muss ich auf den
Beitrag von den Grünen eingehen denn das
kann man so nicht stehen lassen
was was sie hier gesagt haben das stimmt
in keiner Weise die unionsgeführte
Bundesregierung hat so viel in die
Schiene und auch in den Radverkehr
investiert wie noch keine
Bundesregierung vorher in der Geschichte
der Bundesrepublik
und ich kann meine drei Minuten Redezeit
leider jetzt nicht nutzen um ihre Rede
hier komplett auseinanderzunehmen aber
ich kann Ihnen eines sagen sie können
nur hoffen dass ihre Rede heute keinen
Faktencheck unterzogen wird Herr Kollege
und viele Menschen hier in Deutschland
die hätten sich von ihnen genau wie von
der Ampelkoalition Antworten gewünscht
auf drängende Probleme und Fragen die
viele beschäftigen zum Beispiel wie kann
unsere Infrastruktur auch in 10 in 15 in
20 Jahren leistungsfähig sein wie wird
marode Infrastruktur saniert wie stehen
sie zur wichtigen
Infrastrukturprojekten gerade zum
Schienenausbau den wir als Union in den
letzten Jahren bis zur Bundestagswahl
vorangetrieben haben das sind Antworten
die sie hier hätten geben müssen und und
Herr Kollege Herr Kollege da gab es
weder ein Bekenntnis zum
Bundesverkehrswegeplan es gab auch kein
Bekenntnis zum Autobahnausbau in
Deutschland und und Herr Kollege es gab
in keiner Weise hier irgendeine Aussage
dazu wie Infrastrukturprojekte in
Deutschland beschleunigt werden können
all das ist für den Logistikstandort in
Deutschland von enormer Bedeutung
und
stattdessen haben sie hier heute im
Bundestag bei Debatten vorher ein
Plädoyer abgegeben das in Zukunft noch
weiter Milliarden nach dem
gießkanntprinzip in Deutschland
ausgeschüttet werden sollen und das
Problem der Politik der Ampelkoalition
ist derzeit folgendes viele Milliarden
werden unreflektiert ausgegeben es wird
gerade mittelfristig beim Investition in
die Infrastruktur gespart und wer an der
Infrastruktur spart der legt die Axt an
die Bundesrepublik Deutschland
und daher kann ich nur sagen
unterstützen Sie hier die Initiative der
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion wir sagen
klar
Infrastrukturausbau muss ganz nach oben
auf die Agenda wir sagen klar wir
brauchen eine planungsbeschleunigung und
wir brauchen wir brauchen auch ein
Autobahnausbau genauso wie den
Schienenausbau und den radwegeausbau und
insgesamt mehr Investitionen in die
Infrastruktur und bitte unterstützen Sie
den Antrag und ändern Sie ihre fatale
Politik herzlichen Dank
[Applaus]
und für die SPD-Fraktion hat das Wort
Sebastian Roloff
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen Herr Kollege
Ploss ich habe ihrer Rede aufmerksam
zugehört es war ja quasi eine Bewerbung
als Verkehrsminister da bin ich ja schon
mal ganz begeistert ich werde das
weiterverfolgen allerdings eher so
Verkehrsminister der Qualität Dobrind
scheuer also da vielleicht noch mal
überlegen ob da nicht ein bisschen mehr
Substanz geht aber für die Opposition
hat es ja auf jeden Fall schon mal
gereicht ich bin darüber hinaus
tatsächlich über den talaspekt dieses
Antrags sehr froh der die Wichtigkeit
der güterverkehrs- und Logistikbranche
für Deutschland bestätigt ja das finde
ich völlig richtig und auch die Analyse
dass die Einschränkungen der Kapazität
durch Schäden an der Infrastruktur
gerade im Bereich Straße und Schiene
maßgeblich sind ist auch korrekt dass
man das wenn man wie die CSU seit 2009
den Verkehrsminister gestellt hat
vielleicht nicht mit ganz so dicken
Backen sagen sollte ist ein anderes
Thema aber der Handlungsbedarf ist
tatsächlich da
die güterverkehrs- und Logistikbranche
ist in Salzburg Graf für die
wirtschaftliche Entwicklung wenn Güter
produziert werden wenn gehandelt wird
müssen die transportiert werden es
braucht funktionierende Lieferketten und
kontinuierlichen Warenfluss und da haben
wir aktuell aus mehreren Richtungen das
Problem und wenn dann noch zu den
wirtschaftlichen Verwerfungen Kraftstoff
und Energiepreise die durch die Decke
gehen dazu kommt wird die Situation noch
schwieriger da braucht es kurzfristige
Hilfen kurzfristigen Eingriff und es
braucht langfristige Investitionen gut
dass wir die auf den Weg gebracht haben
und hier mit der Ampel die
entsprechenden Maßnahmen angestoßen
haben
der Koalitionsvertrag liegt völlig zu
Recht den Fokus sowohl auf den Transport
per Schiff per Bahn und in der Luft und
auf der Straße da ist völlig klar dass
wir insbesondere mit Blick auf die
Klimaneutralität die unser aller Ziel
und die Fortschritte hier die wir uns
zusammen vornehmen sollten ist und das
ist eben völlig richtig ich glaube dass
die Strömung gaspreisbremse die sicher
schnell auf den Weg gebracht wird nicht
nur die Branche entlastet sondern auch
die Krise beim Thema AdBlue zeitnah
beendet und darüber hinaus müssen sich
Unternehmen natürlich überlegen wie ihre
Lieferketten
Krisen weniger krisenanfällig sind als
aktuell ich habe mich sehr gefreut dass
die jüngste Umfrage des ifo-Instituts
ergeben hat dass die vergangenen Monate
von vielen Unternehmen schon genutzt
worden die Lieferketten anzupassen und
die Beschaffungsstrategien zu verändern
die Wirtschaft reagiert und es ist
unsere gemeinsame Aufgabe und das weiß
ich aus meiner Tätigkeit vor dem
Deutschen Bundestag wo ich als
hatten da Funktionen bei einem
Lkw-Hersteller tätig war die Unternehmen
arbeiten jeden Tag an
Zukunftstechnologien weil klar ist das
klimaneutrale Antriebe die Zukunft sind
und unser Auftrag als Politik ist es
diesen Weg zu unterstützen
selbstverständlich nicht nur im
Personenverkehr sondern gerade was das
Thema liefern auf Schiene und Straße
betrifft wir müssen sicherstellen dass
die Unternehmen die Finanzmittel haben
um weiterhin Forschung und Entwicklungen
investieren zu können und an diesen Weg
gemeinsam weitergehen vielen Dank
der Bundestag diskutiert über den
Güterverkehr und die Logistikbranche die
auch unter den hohen Gas- und
Energiepreisen zu leiten haben und
Stefan Seidler spricht als nächstes
[Applaus]
derzeit nicht lieferbar das lesen wir
gerade immer wieder im Online-Handel
oder am warenregal die Probleme in der
Güterverkehr und Logistikbranche Märkten
die Menschen in unserem Land nicht
zuletzt daran das Produkte nicht mehr
schnell verfügbar sind
Lieferschwierigkeiten sind nicht nur
Ärgernis für Verbraucherinnen und
Verbraucher sie haben das Potenzial
Menschenleben zu gefährden und unserer
Wirtschaft zu schaden unverständlich ist
für mich dass im Antrag der cdu/csu
Zustände angemahnt werden die sie selbst
hätten verhindern können die Lösungen
wirken altbacken und von vorgestern
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen der Union
wir müssen doch Vorankommen in diesem
Land wir müssen die Verkehrswende
vorantreiben mehr für die Schiene und
mir für die Wasserstraße
die in Koalitionsvertrag formulierten
Ziele zum Beispiel von 25% Anteil für
den Schienengüterverkehr bis 2030 sind
ambitioniert und auch begrüßenswert aber
ich frage mich auch lieber
Ampelkoalition wo bleibt denn eigentlich
der schienenwumms damit wir ans Ziel
ankommen lieber ampelfraktion sie hatten
sich vorgenommen gegen den
Fachkräftemangel mehr zu tun aus meinen
Gesprächen mit Firmen aus der Branche in
meiner Heimat im Norden weiß ich hier
passiert leider viel zu wenig uns fehlen
nicht nur berufskraftfahrerinnen und
Kraftfahrer im Straßengüterverkehr
sondern bei den lokführerinnen und
Lokführern besteht ein akuter
Fachkräftemangel ich habe deshalb
kürzlich direkt eine Frage an die
Bundesregierung gewandt um zu erfragen
was die Bundesregierung und die Deutsche
Bahn AG tun um diese Situation zu
verbessern verbessern und ich ahne
bereits oder ich hoffe es zumindest dass
die Antwort sein wird wir müssen mehr
ausbilden
wie Sie wissen komme ich aus einer
Grenzregion lassen Sie mich Ihnen sagen
wenn wir zukünftig unsere Resilienz im
Bereich des Transportes stärken wollen
dann müssen wir langfristig unsere
Infrastruktur ertüchtigen kurzfristig
mehrfachpersonal ausbilden und sobald
wie möglich einen reibungslosen
Grenzverkehr mit unseren Nachbarländern
sicherstellen denn wo Grenzen
geschlossen werden steigen Kosten
brechen Lieferketten kommt
wirtschaftliche Tätigkeit zum Erliegen
und reißen Kontakte auch ich danke für
Ihre
Stefan Seidler war das vom
südschleswegischen wählerverband ist
fraktionslos kriegt hier aber auch von
den anderen Fraktionen Applaus nächster
Redner ist Hennig Reborn für die
cdu/csu-fraktion Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen
die Vorredner haben hier interessante
Thesen aufgestellt ich möchte Herrn
Seidler an der Stelle recht geben wir
brauchen mehr Geld für Schiene und für
Wasserstraßen nur steht das leider
aktuell im Haushalt der Ampel nicht drin
und Herr schiefner die Problemanalyse
ist immer da und sie erzählen uns viel
was im Koalitionsvertrag drin steht das
ist alles ganz nett aber das hilft den
Spediteuren überhaupt nicht 25% ihrer
Regierungszeit sind bereits vorbei
fangen Sie endlich an
das zentrale Problem ist ja der
Fahrermangel mehr als 60.000
Berufskraftfahrer fehlen schon jetzt 35
Prozent gehen in den nächsten Jahren in
Rente die Ampel ist hier viel zu
zögerlich und wenn es so weitergeht dann
haben wir englische Verhältnisse und
leere Regale
die Branche die Branche hat die
Ausbildungsstandards für LKW-Fahrer
selbst hochgefahren um den fahrerberuf
und die Sicherheitsstandards aufzuwerten
das ist aller Ehren wert das fällt uns
allerdings jetzt ein Stück weit auf die
Füße denn durch Demografie Corona und
die ukraine-krise fehlen Fahrer nicht
nur in Deutschland sondern ist in
europaweites Phänomen dazu kostet in
Deutschland der Führerschein ungefähr
10.000 Euro und dauert ein halbes Jahr
eine Lösung ist die Standards bei der
fahrerausbildung auf eine europäisches
Normalmaß herunterzufahren
zurückzufahren und nach dem Vorbild
Österreichs und eine bessere Anerkennung
ausländischer Führerscheine türkische
albanische oder serbische Lkw-Fahrer
fahren ihr ganzes Leben in Europa da
muss man sich bei der Anerkennung der
Führerscheine kein Loch ins Knie bohren
ein echtes Ärgernis ist das Auswärtige
Amt das seit 56 Jahren von FDP SPD oder
grünen geführt wird die visa-verfahren
sind viel zu schleppend wenn man in
Drittstaaten gerne für für eine deutsche
Firma einen LKW fahren möchte dann
wartet man mal eben sechs Monate auf
einen Termin im Konsulat das ist
inakzeptabel
den Bürgern großspurig im Wahlkampf
fachkräftezuwanderung versprechen kann
man Außenministerin beerbock genauso wie
ihr Vorgänger Heiko Maas von der SPD
schaffen es aber nicht genügend Personal
in die Konsulate unendlich visaprozesse
zu beschleunigen Ministerin baerbock
stocken sie das Personal in den
Konsulaten auf damit Lkw-Fahrer schnell
einen Termin und zügig ein Visum
bekommen können
eine Maßnahme die kein Geld kostet
möchte ich noch kurz vorstellen seit
Jahren führen SPD Grüne und deren
befreundete Vorfeldorganisationen einen
ideologischen Kampf gegen den LKW
Klimakiller LKW LKWs raus aus unseren
Städten
Lkw-Fahrer berichten mir von
Anfeindungen und verächtlichen Gesten
von Passanten wenn sie durch Dörfer und
Städte fahren Kolleginnen und Kollegen
liebe Gäste auf der Tribüne das kommt
dabei raus wenn man jahrelang Stimmung
gegen den LKW macht das führt dazu dass
niemand mehr Fernfahrer werden will
wir in der Politik haben große
Verantwortung ich komme zum Schluss
sprechen wir ab sofort gut über den LKW
sprechen wir gut über den Beruf des
Fernfahrers geben wir den Menschen die
tagtäglich weit weg von zu Hause für
unseren Wohlstand auf Achse sind ihre
Würde zurück sie haben es verdient
und die letzte Rednerin der Debatte für
die SPD-Fraktion ist Anja trov scharvats
frau Präsidentin sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
die cdu/csu fährt mit ihrem Antrag hier
mal wieder einen Angriff auf breitester
Front Infrastruktur AdBlue LNG
Fahrermangel alles ist drin und das
nicht zum ersten Mal das erste Mal haben
wir erst im Juni hier über den
Personalmangel gesprochen in einer
Branche die sie ja nicht zu Unrecht als
eine der wichtigsten in Deutschland
darstellen aber auch ihr neuer Antrag
suggeriert wieder dass nichts getan
werden würde für diese Branche und das
stimmt so nicht wie ihnen der Kollege
schiefler ja auch schon deutlich in
Stammbuch geschrieben hat
ich greife mir zwei weitere Punkte aus
ihrem Antrag raus wo ich ihre Analyse
gerne ergänzen möchte nämlich AdBlue und
LNG bei beiden Themen ist das Fazit ja
wir haben noch einen Weg zu gehen aber
bei beiden Themen sage ich auch es ist
nicht richtig so zu tun als würde hier
nichts passieren als die ersten Berichte
zu Problemen im beim Nachschub von
AdBlue kam hat sich das Ministerium
umgehend eingeschaltet wie gerade auch
der Staatssekretär Lucid im deutlich
gemacht hat gemeinsam mit den relevanten
Herstellern in Deutschland wurden die
Lieferungen sichergestellt und zwar auch
gerade im Namen der Logistikbranche
und auch beim LNG gilt alle Fachleute
bestätigen uns dass wir ab 2023
signifikante Mengen Bio LNG zur
Verfügung haben werden auf dem Markt das
wird der Branche helfen die
angeschafften Fahrzeuge wirtschaftlich
in Betrieb zu nehmen und eben auch zu
halten
was wir bis dahin tun können das
besprechen wir der Kollege Roloff hat
ist hier vorhin gesagt die geplanten
preisbremsen helfen natürlich auch der
Logistik
ich möchte Ihnen aber noch einmal
ergänzen sagen dass wir ein weit
größeres Problem haben werden wenn wir
jetzt überall Krisenstimmung
heraufbeschwören wie Sie es gerade tun
und das zumal in einer Branche die durch
Kostendruck Arbeitsbelastung und
verschlechterte Rahmenbedingungen in den
letzten Jahren für junge Arbeitnehmer
zunehmend unattraktiv geworden ist ein
Spediteur aus meinem Wahlkreis hat mir
gesagt und Spediteuren kann es egal sein
ob wir mit 100 Fahrzeugen unser Geld
verdienen oder nur mit zwei aber das
Problem dass wir am Ende haben dass
nämlich die Regale leer bleiben und die
Produktion stillstehen weil niemand mehr
die Dinge transportieren kann das haben
wir dann als Gesellschaft alle gemeinsam
und darum sage ich zum Schluss was ich
so ähnlich auch schon im Juni gesagt
habe wir wollen keine schönen Färberei
betreiben die Lieferketten stehen unter
großem Druck wir sollten uns als Politik
aber fokussiert daran machen die Branche
wieder attraktiv zu machen für den
Nachwuchs sonst brauchen wir nicht über
weitere Zukunftsfragen die neue Antriebe
gar nicht zu sprechen gerne besprechen
wir das gemeinsame im Ausschuss aber
dann lassen Sie uns bitte die richtigen
Schwerpunkte setzen vielen Dank
Anja Treff schawatzik war das für die
SPD-Fraktion die letzte Rednerin hier in
dieser Debatte dieser Antrag der
Unionsfraktion wird jetzt an die
entsprechenden Ausschüsse überwiesen
federführend ist der Verkehrsausschuss
und damit kommen wir zu einem anderen
Thema das nicht so einfach ist zu
debattieren das musste auch schon die
Ampel feststellen es geht um das
Infektionsschutzgesetz und wie Menschen
mit Behinderung vor Benachteiligung
geschützt werden können wenn es nicht
genügend Kapazitäten
gibt da geht es unter anderem um die
sogenannte
ex-posttriage also die Frage ob und
unter welchen Voraussetzungen bei einem
Patienten die medizinische
Intensivbehandlung abgebrochen werden
kann um einen anderen Patienten einen
Überleben zu ermöglichen
das ist ein intensives Thema und der
Bundesgesundheitsminister Karl
Lauterbach hat nun hier ein
Gesetzentwurf vorgelegt indem er eben
regeln möchte dass Patienten nicht wegen
einer Behinderung des Grades der
Gebrechlichkeit des Alters der Herkunft
Religion Weltanschauung Geschlecht oder
sexuellen Orientierung benachteiligt
werden dürfen allerdings gibt es von den
Grünen doch Bedenken ob dieser
Gesetzentwurf ausreicht Karl Lauterbach
spricht nun dazu
frau Präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir reden heute
über eine sehr wichtige Frage die Frage
nach der Triage im Rahmen der
infektionsschutzversorgung und es ist
wichtig darauf hinzuweisen dass es Gott
sei Dank so gewesen ist dass diese
zentrale Frage im Rahmen der
pandemiebewältigung bisher nie eine
Rolle gespielt hat sie hat keine
praktische Rolle gespielt dabei soll es
auch bleiben
aber soll es auch planen wir haben in
unseren Krankenhäusern nie die triarch
praktizieren müssen ist auch unser Ziel
das weiter zu verhindern einen Rückblick
wir haben 2020 2021 erhebliche
Belastungen in den Krankenhäusern gehabt
wir haben es aber durch die Einführung
des kleeblattsystems zu jeder Zeit
geschafft die Patienten so in
Deutschland zu verteilen und zu
versorgen dass es keinen einzigen mir
bekannten Fall einer Triage im Rahmen
der Versorgung von covid-patienten
gegeben hat das ist eine große Leistung
unseres Gesundheitssystems aber auch
eine große Leistung der Pflegekräfte und
der Ärzteschaft ich möchte mich an
dieser Stelle noch einmal ganz
ausdrücklich hier bei allen die daran
teil gehabt haben die dazu beigetragen
haben ganz ganz herzlich im Namen auch
der Bundesregierung bedanken
trotzdem müssen wir alles dazu tun dass
es auch so bleibt und da müssen wir
wachsam sein wir müssen die Pandemie
weiter im Griff behalten es ist leider
so die Pandemie ist leider nicht beendet
wie die Blicke auf den Pandemie Radar
hier zeigen wir haben derzeit steigende
Fallzahlen wir haben eine Mehrbelastung
erneut auf den Intensivstationen wir
haben auch wieder mehr schwere Fälle
auch die Sterblichkeit steigt leider
wieder und es ist auch nicht
ausgeschlossen dass wir über den Winter
andere Varianten bekommen die uns vor
neue Herausforderungen stellen daher
brauchen wir dieses Gesetz es ist ein
Gesetz wo wir immer hoffen dass wir es
nie anwenden müssen aber wir müssen es
haben denn wir müssen sicherstellen und
das ist das Wichtigste was wir mit
diesem Gesetz verfolgen wir müssen
sicherstellen dass Menschen mit
Behinderung und schweren Vorerkrankungen
nicht wegen ihrer Behinderung oder
Bewegen der Vorerkrankungen war der
Zuteilung von wichtigen Lebens
erhaltenden versorgungsmaßnahmen
benachteiligt werden das darf nicht
passieren unsere Gesellschaft ist immer
so menschlich wie sie mit denjenigen
umgeht die die meisten Nachteile haben
und die sich am wenigsten wehren können
das sind die Menschen in akuter Not die
mit Behinderung möglicherweise auch mit
geistigen Schwierigkeiten und mit
Vorerkrankungen unter denen sich schon
genug gelitten haben dann auch noch in
einer solche Situation kommen wo sie
eine akute versorgen benötigen und da
dürfen sie nicht benachteiligt werden
wegen der Nachteile die sich schon ihr
ganzes Leben erleiden müssen das ist der
Sinn dieses Gesetzes
wir haben daher hier Klarstellung und
Rechtssicherheit geschaffen das ist die
Essenz des Gesetzentwurfes niemand darf
aufgrund einer Behinderung oder einer
Vorerkrankung bei der
intensivmedizinischen Behandlung
benachteiligt werden das bedeutet jedes
Leben hat für uns grundlegend die
gleiche Bedeutung die gleiche
Berechtigung ich möchte an dieser Stelle
daran erinnern dass das Lager in dunklen
Zeiten unserer Geschichte nicht der Fall
gewesen ist nicht der Fall gewesen ist
und daher ist es sehr wichtig dass wir
uns noch einmal vergewissern wo wir hier
stehen wir sind eine Gesellschaft die
das Leben eines jeden gleich zählt und
das bringen wir hier auch zum Ausdruck
in dem es keinerlei Benachteiligungen
geben kann für Menschen mit Behinderung
mit Nachteilen oder mit Vorerkrankungen
die sonst diese Möglichkeiten nicht
hätten
ich möchte bei dieser Gelegenheit mich
auch ausdrücklich bedanken für die
kompetente
Beratung und Diskussion die wir geführt
haben mit dem Beauftragten der
Bundesregierung für die Belange von
Menschen mit Behinderung Jürgen Dusel er
hat uns wirklich hier in vielen
Diskussionen einen weggewiesen den wir
gerne gehen den wir gerne mitgehen aber
ich möchte das hier sagen also dass wir
ihm auch dem Beauftragten ausdrücklich
danken er hat die Perspektive der
Menschen eingebracht die auf der anderen
Seite stehen die diese Leistungen
möglicherweise irgendwann benötigen
wollen daher möchte ich ihm danken für
die aufklärende Sicht die hier
eindringen konnte wir wollen auch
Rechtssicherheit für die Ärztinnen und
Ärzte haben es geht darum die
Überlebenswahrscheinlichkeit die vor der
Behandlung besteht darf hier nicht durch
die Behinderung benachteiligende Effekte
haben Behinderung und Grad der
Gebrechlichkeit dürfen keine Rolle
spielen damit das auch funktioniert
haben wir das mehrorgen-prinzip für die
Entscheidung ein
dazu führt dass es vorgesehen wenn ein
Mensch mit Behinderung und
Vorerkrankungen betroffen ist dann muss
auch noch ein weiterer Experte der sich
mit dieser Erkrankung oder Behinderung
auskennt hinzugezogen werden somit haben
wir einen meeraugen-prinzip und die
Sicherstellung der notwendigen Expertise
so dass wir in der Regel
klarkommen wenn es dann auch noch eine
Uneinigkeit gibt dann sind noch weitere
Maßnahmen hier vorgesehen aber was mehr
Augens Prinzip mit der entsprechenden
also
Expertise aus den betroffenen Bereich
sichert dass das Ganze fair und gerecht
zuläuft und das ganze wird dann
dokumentiert wir haben umfängliche
Dokumentationspflichten eingeführt ich
schließe ab das ist ein klarer Kompass
für unsere Gesellschaft der klare
Kompass für unsere Gesellschaft bedeutet
in einer solchen Situation sind
Behinderung und Benachteiligung sind
Vorerkrankungen kein Grund die
Versorgung nicht zu lassen Sie mich
abschließend noch sagen es wird keine
export-real geben das heißt derjenige
derjenige wo die Behandlung schon
begonnen hat derjenige wo die Behandlung
schon begonnen hat der kann sich darauf
verlassen dass die Behandlung auch
fortgeführt wird so dass niemand
befürchten muss dass die Behandlung
abgebrochen wird nur damit die
Behandlungsplätze einem Dritten zu Tal
werden das kann nicht angehen die
exporttrierisch wird es bei uns nicht
geben ich danke Ihnen
Bundesgesundheitsminister Karl
Lauterbach hat hier
zum ersten Mal über sein Gesetzentwurf
gesprochen Hubert hüppel spricht in nun
für die Unionsfraktion meine Damen und
Herren liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen am
28 dezember 2021 hat das
Bundesverfassungsgericht seine
Entscheidung zur sogenannten triasch
veröffentlicht Menschen mit Behinderung
haben geklagt weil sie Angst hatten
benachteiligt zu werden wenn es nicht
genug Behandlungskapazitäten gibt im
Grundgesetz steht niemand darf wegen
seiner Behinderung benachteiligt werden
und tatsächlich hat das Gericht im Sinne
der Klägerinnen entschieden der
Gesetzgeber hat gegen dieses
Benachteiligungsverbot verstoßen ich
zitiere weil er es unterlassen hat
Vorkehrungen zu treffen damit niemand
wegen einer Behinderung auf die
Zuteilung über lebenswichtiger nicht für
alle zur Verfügung stehender
intensivmedizinischer Ressourcen
benachteiligt wird am selben Tag Herr
Minister haben sie getwittert ich
begrüße das Urteil des BVG ausdrücklich
Menschen mit grundbedürfen mehr als alle
anderen den Schutzes durch den Staat und
wer sich dem vorliegenden Gesetzentwurf
allerdings ansieht der muss feststellen
dass Herr Lauterbach zwar den Schutz
begrüßt aber ihn im vorliegenden Gesetz
nicht schafft meine Damen und Herren und
das ist nicht nur meine Meinung sondern
das ist durchgängig die Meinung aller
Behindertenverbände die ich kenne und
der Grundfehler ist dass er in der dass
er die triat im
Infektionsschutzgesetz regelt also nur
dann wenn es aufgrund einer
übertragbaren Krankheit nicht
ausreichend über lebenswichtige
intensivmedizinische Behandlung
Kapazitäten gibt das bedeutet aber in
Umkehrschluss dass alle anderen
triatischen Situationen ungeregelt
bleiben also zum Beispiel bei
Naturkatastrophen beim Reaktor unter bei
Flugzeugabsturz kriech oder
Terroranschlag
ungeregelt bleiben auch alle Situationen
zur Zuteilung von Behandlungskapazitäten
außer Intensivmedizin zum Beispiel bei
Arzneimittel bei Blutkonserven Plätze im
Rettungswagen meine Damen und Herren
tatsächlich der Anlass war erst coweg 19
aber wenn es wirklich zu
behandlungsfesten kommt dann herrscht
die Diskriminierung doch auch bei
Flutkatastrophen oder anderen
Katastrophen und wenn wir die Menschen
schützen wollen und wenn wir wollen dass
Sie nicht diskriminiert werden in der
Medizin dann müssen wir das mit hier
rein nehmen und nicht nur im
infektionsgesetz sondern dafür möchte
erweise ein eigenes Gesetz oder das AGG
meine Damen und Herren
ein weiterer Fall ist auch
dass der nächste Fall ist auch dass sie
zwar schreiben das haben sie ja gerade
auch gesagt mehr augenprinzip Facharzt
Erfordernis und Dokumentationspflicht
allerdings das muss man hier auch sagen
wenn man dagegen verstößt gibt es weder
eine Strafe noch ein Bußgeld und meine
Damen und Herren schauen Sie sich das
Infektionsschutzgesetz an hinten sind
ganz viele Bußgelder aufgeführt
Meldepflichten aufgeführt Bestrafungen
aufgeführt alles steht dort nur nicht
bei triat und da geht es um Leben oder
Tod aber wenn sie wirklich einen Schutz
wollen von Menschen mit Behinderung der
effektiv ist so wie es das
Verfassungsgericht fordert meine Damen
und Herren da muss es dort auch
Sanktionen geben sonst ist es kein
Schutz für die Menschen
und noch nichtmals noch nichtmals eine
Meldepflicht schreiben sie vor bei allen
Dingen müssen sie irgendwas mögen da
haben sie ganz viele mildevorschriften
die sind auch aufgeführt aber
ausgerechnet bei den triarden muss man
nichts melden das heißt wir hören können
überhaupt nicht prüfen weil sie gar
nicht wissen ob so etwas stattgefunden
hat und deswegen ist dieser Entwurf aus
meiner Sicht nicht tragbar
meine Damen und Herren ein letztes im
Koalitionsvertrag steht bei der Ampel
dass sie Menschen mit Behinderung bei
allen Gesetzen sehr stark beteiligen
wollen mehr als die sie vorher der Fall
ist bei diesem Gesetz haben sie die
betroffenen Menschen nicht besonders gut
beteiligt noch heute warten die Menschen
mit Behinderung auf Antworten auf Fragen
die an ihrem Ministerium geschickt
worden sind die sind bis heute nicht
beantwortet und wenn Sie nicht mit dem
betroffenen Menschen sprechen
dann machen Sie hier einen großen Fehler
denn es geht um deren Leben um deren
Situationen und bei ihnen sieht es so
aus Herr Minister dass Sie dass dieser
Gesetzentwurf ein Dokument des Unwillens
ist dass dem Anliegen der Klägerin nicht
gerecht wird vielen Dank
hat hier deutliche Kritik an den
Gesundheitsminister geäußert er war vier
Jahre lang von 2010 bis 2014 selber
Beauftragte der Bundesregierung für die
Belange von Menschen mit Behinderungen
Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen als vor über zehn Jahren die
UN-Behindertenrechtskonvention
ratifiziert wurde ist damit ein
Paradigmenwechsel eingeläutet worden es
geht um nicht weniger als darum eine
inklusive Gesellschaft Wirklichkeit
werden zu lassen bis heute aber gibt es
keinen Lebensbereich der wirklich
diskriminierungsfrei ist leider auch
nicht unser Gesundheitswesen auch wenn
wir Ärztinnen
wie ich auch alle Profis im
Gesundheitssystem ihr Bestes geben und
auch in dieser Pandemie dafür gesorgt
haben das glücklicherweise eine solche
zuteilungsentscheidung nicht getroffen
werden musste so gibt es doch wenn wir
uns ehrlich machen und ein Finger Nase
Versuch machen
Diskriminierung im Gesundheitswesen sie
passiert und zwar häufig unbewusst und
darum sind Betroffene als die Ressourcen
wegen der corona-notlage knapp wurden
vor das Bundesverfassungsgericht gezogen
und sie haben Recht bekommen Menschen
mit Behinderung dürfen bei der Zuteilung
über lebensnotwendiger Ressourcen nicht
benachteiligt werden und das ist uns
Auftrag der vorliegende Gesetzentwurf
muss also wichtiges erfüllen und er
erfüllt zentrale wichtige Anforderungen
für Menschen mit Behinderung muss
sichergestellt werden dass sie im Fall
einer Triage nicht etwa aufgrund von
Diskriminierung kein Lebens sichernden
Platz bekommen
die Person die im Gesundheitswesen
arbeiten und Verantwortung tragen
brauchen Rechtssicherheit und der
Gesetzentwurf muss dafür sorgen dass das
praktikabel und anwendbar in
Ausnahmesituationen ist
und das ist nicht trivial und darum
befassen wir uns auch in einer Anhörung
jetzt natürlich damit noch mal wo
verschiedene Blickwinkel zum Tragen
kommen von Ärzteverbänden von Menschen
mit Behinderung ein solches Gesetz muss
darum befristet und evaluiert werden
und ich begrüße sehr dass der
Bundesgesundheitsminister gerade noch
mal klargestellt hat dass die Expos
Triage ausgeschlossen bleibt das ist
wichtig für das Vertrauensverhältnis
zwischen ÄrztInnen und Patientin und für
mehr Klarheit statt für mehr
Unsicherheit und in den vergangenen
Jahren der Pandemie haben Vorsorge und
der hohe Einsatz der Menschen im
Gesundheitswesen Ärztin Pflegerin alle
dafür gesorgt dass eine solche
zuteilungsentscheidung nicht gefällt
werden musste das ist gut und
wahrscheinlich wird auch der vorliegende
Gesetzentwurf nie zur Anwendung kommen
müssen hoffentlich nicht
doch er ist erheblich dennoch künftige
Entscheidung werden sich potenziell an
diesem Gesetz orientieren Herr Hüppe
das A und O ist es steht in unserer
Verantwortung alles dafür zu tun dass es
auch weiterhin nicht zu einer solchen
Notsituation kommt und wir müssen
sicherstellen dass auch die Zugänge zum
Versorgungssystem funktionieren das ist
keine sogenannte vortriage gibt unser
gemeinsames Ziel ob beschäftigt dem
Gesundheitssystem oder Menschen mit
Behinderung muss doch ein inklusives
Gesundheitswesen sein daher ist noch ein
Weg zu gehen ich finde wir sollten den
gemeinsam gehen ich danke Ihnen
Kirsten Köppert Gunther war das für die
Grünen Fraktion sie sitzt du auf der
nächste Redner im Gesundheitsausschuss
Jörg Schneider spricht jetzt für die
afd-fraktion Frau Präsidentin meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren 2020 sahen wir
schreckliche Bilder aus Italien und aus
Frankreich Menschen erkrankten schwer an
Corona es gab nicht genug
Beatmungsgeräte Ärzten mussten
entscheiden wer wird beatmet werden
nicht diese Entscheidungssituation
nennen wir Triage in Deutschland hatten
vor allen Dingen Behinderte Angst dass
sie in einer solchen Situation wenn Sie
den in Deutschland auftreten würde
benachteiligt werden das
Verfassungsgericht gab ihnen recht
deswegen diskutieren wir heute eine
Änderung einer Ergänzung des
Infektionsschutzgesetzes um eine
triasregelung da stehen jetzt viele
Kriterien drin die bei einer
triage-entscheidung nicht berücksichtigt
werden dürfen und ich glaube wir sind
uns einig die sexuelle Orientierung die
Weltanschauung die Religion die dürfen
keine Rolle spielen wenn es darum geht
wer kriegt das letzte Beatmungsgerät
aber das Alter wir wissen doch aus
Corona das gerade jüngere Menschen eine
wesentlich bessere Überlebenschance
hatten das darf ein Arzt jetzt nicht
mehr berücksichtigen oder eine
Behinderung ich glaube nicht dass ein
Arzt einen blinden benachteiligt
gegenüber einem nicht sehbehinderten
aber wenn eine Behinderung die Atmung
beeinträchtigt und wir sprechen über
eine eine Erkrankung des
atmungsapparates dann muss es doch
möglich sein dass ein Arzt etwas solches
mit bei seiner Entscheidung
berücksichtigt meine Damen und Herren
der
Generalsekretär des
Bundes der der Vereinigung der
Intensivmediziner Herr Professor Jansen
sagte dazu und ich zitiere wörtlich wenn
Ärzte gezwungen würden Kriterien wie das
Alter oder die Gebrechlichkeit bei
Menschen über 65 Jahren bei der
triageentscheidung pauschal außer Acht
zu lassen dann werden wir
handlungsunfähig Zitat Ende und unsere
Mediziner sind handlungsfähig Trias
findet statt stellen sich vor ein Unfall
viele Schwerverletzte das erste
Rettungsteam trifft dort am Ort ein dann
muss diese traurige Entscheidung
getroffen werden wen können wir retten
das machen die heute schon meine Damen
und Herren und die Frage ist jetzt
können wir diese Erfahrung die dort
gesammelt worden sind in eine
pandemiebedingte
triage-situationen
hineintransferieren und ich sage nein
ihr Gesetzentwurf verhindert dass meine
Damen und Herren
und
auch die Umsetzung die sie hier
vorschlagen erscheint mir doch etwas
weltfremd zwei Ärzte müssen
einvernehmlich entscheiden wenn das
nicht möglich ist sollen Dritter dazu
kommen das ganze soll dokumentiert
werden in einer triage-situation sind
wir in einer Ausnahmezustand da gibt es
dann vielleicht einen Arzt der muss
entscheiden der muss schnell entscheiden
und der hat keine Zeit für eine
Dokumentation ich glaube auch in diesem
Punkt ist ihr Gesetzentwurf noch
dringend überarbeitungsbedürftig meine
Damen und Herren
und schließlich Herr Minister Corona ist
vorbei das sagt nicht nur die
afd-fraktion das sagen die meisten
Regierungen auf dieser Welt und wenn Sie
hier weiterhin mit Fallzahlen Panik
schüren wir wissen doch seit anderthalb
Jahren dass die Inzidenz kein geeignetes
Kriterium ist um eine Notsituation
vorherzusagen und sie versuchen es hier
schon wieder nein wenn Sie eine
Notsituation im Gesundheitssystem
vermeiden wollen dann gibt es zwei
Möglichkeiten schaffen sie endlich die
einrichtungsbezogene Impfpflicht ab wir
wissen geimpfte Pfleger können Patienten
genauso anstecken wie ungeimpfte sie
wird eh nicht durchgesetzt diese
einrichtungsbezogene Impfpflicht und
wenn wir sie durchsetzen wenn ihr dann
hätten wir einen Notstand deswegen weg
mit der einrichtungsbezogenen
Impfpflicht meine Damen und Herren und
gesunde Pfleger und Ärzte die gehören
nicht in Quarantäne
gesunde Ärzte und Pfleger die gehören zu
ihren Patienten deswegen beenden sie
endlich diese vollkommen überzogenen
quarantänevorschriften dann glaube ich
sind wir am e Notsituation geschützt ich
danke Ihnen
und für die
für die Kollegin Katrin Henning klar
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine
Damen und Herren sehr geehrter Herr
Minister vor gut 200 Jahren war es der
armeechirurg Dominik Jean Larry der
Vater der Notärzte der während Napoleon
Bonapartes Feldzügen auf Pferdewagen
fliegende Lazarette einrichtete er
begann damit die Verwundeten nach
Schwere der Verletzung zu sortieren um
möglichst viele Patienten behandeln zu
können was auf dem Schlachtfeld seinen
Ursprung nahm wurde später auch in
zivilen Katastrophenfällen angewandt und
hat inzwischen auch in der medizinischen
Versorgung in Friedenszeiten eine lange
Geschichte
bei der Zuteilung des in den 40er Jahren
9 und knappen Penicillins im Rahmen der
polioepidemien in den 50er Jahren als
nicht ausreichend eiserne Lungen zur
Verfügung stand und in den 60ern als man
mit Dialysebehandlungen begann und nicht
ausreichend Plätze für alle Betroffenen
hatte meine Damen und Herren die
Entscheidung über die Zuteilung knapper
medizinischer Ressourcen ist oft nicht
weniger als die Entscheidung über die
Frage von Leben und Tod
Ärzte haben sich der Rettung
menschlichen Lebens verschrieben sie
haben gelobt wenn ich aus der
Deklaration von Genf zitieren darf die
Gesundheit und das Wohlergehen meiner
Patientin oder meines Patienten werden
mein oberstes Anliegen sein kein Arzt
trifft eine zuteilungsentscheidung
leichtfertig aber es gibt Situationen da
muss er sie treffen gegebenenfalls auch
einmal in einer pandemie-situation in
der ein Krankenhaus an der absoluten
überlastungsgrenze steht und auch er an
der körperlichen Belastungsgrenze
arbeitet in solchen Ausnahmesituationen
ist es dann so hat es das
Bundesverfassungsgericht festgestellt
nicht immer gewährleistet das absolut
diskriminierungsfrei entschieden wird in
solchen Situationen ist es nicht immer
ausgeschlossen dass gerade Menschen mit
einer Behinderung bei der Zuteilung
intensivmedizinischer Ressourcen
benachteiligt werden nicht weil
Ärztinnen und Ärzte diskriminieren
wollen sondern weil es sein könnte dass
sie die Überlebenswahrscheinlichkeit
nicht richtig einschätzen das
Bundesverfassungsgericht hat es
unbewusste Stereotypisierung genannt
deshalb ist es an uns als Gesetzgeber
Vorkehrungen zu treffen damit niemand
wegen einer Behinderung oder
Vorerkrankung bei der Zuteilung über
lebenswichtiger nicht für alle zur
Verfügung stehende intensivmedizinischer
Ressourcen benachteiligt wird dieser
Verantwortung kommen mit diesem
Gesetzentwurf nach zugleich vergessen
wir aber natürlich nicht dass das
vordringliche Ziel sein muss die
Entstehung von triagesituationen zu
vermeiden wenn es aber doch dazu kommt
dann ist es richtig dass anhand der
aktuellen und kurzfristigen
Überlebenswahrscheinlichkeit entschieden
wird dieses Kriterium hat ja auch das
Bundesverfassungsgericht als
grundgesetzkonformes Kriterium genannt
konkret und auf eine pandemiebezogen
welcher Patient wird die akute Infektion
mit höherer Wahrscheinlichkeit überleben
los Entscheidung wie zum Teil ja auch
gefordert wurde hielte ich für abwegig
die aktuelle
und kurzfristige
Überlebenswahrscheinlichkeit der
Patienten entscheiden zu lassen ist
wesentlich gerechter als Leben gegen
leben auszuwürfeln
denn nur dieses Kriterium wird der
scheinbaren Kontradiktion gerecht dass
einerseits ein Leben genauso viel wert
ist wie das andere dass wir leben weder
bewerten können noch wollen dass wir
aber andererseits so viele Menschenleben
retten wollen wie es eben geht
bei der zur Bestimmung der aktuellen
kurzfristigen
Überlebenswahrscheinlichkeit
erforderlichen und sicher nicht immer
einfacher Prognose darf selbst reden
nicht deskriminiert werden insbesondere
nicht wegen einer Behinderung einer
Vorerkrankung des Alters der ethnischen
Herkunft der Religion oder
Weltanschauung des Geschlechts oder der
sexuellen Orientierung das wollen wir
nun auch im Gesetz festhalten zur
Absicherung für alle Beteiligten müssen
qualifizierte Ärzte in einem
Vier-Augen-Prinzip entscheiden bei
Begleiterkrankungen oder Behinderungen
muss zudem noch ein fachlich insoweit
besonders versierter Mediziner
hinzugezogen werden ich finde das ist
ein guter Weg einer potenziellen
diskriminierungsgefahr zu begegnen wir
müssen bei diesem existenziellen Thema
natürlich alle Aspekte genau Wägen
deshalb sehe ich der weiteren Diskussion
im Ausschuss entgegen vielen Dank
Katrin Helling klar war das für die FDP
auf sie folgt athisch kippinal von der
Linksfraktion erst Sprecher für
Krankenhaus und pflegepolitik
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren liegt das
Gesetz zur Triage vor mit diesem Gesetz
soll ein Rahmen geschaffen werden wie
Entscheidung überleben und Tod getroffen
werden sollen bevor ich ein paar Sätze
über diese zentrale ethische
Fragestellung verlieren möchte lassen
Sie mich festhalten dass dieses Gesetz
sehr deutlich macht wie unmoralisch das
profitorientierte System ist indem wir
leben und dass dies insbesondere im
Gesundheitssystem nun wirklich gar
nichts verloren hat warum das
profitorientierte System schafft
künstliche Knappheit für Katastrophen
und vorhergesehen und unvorhergesehen
und unvorhergesehene Ereignisse zwar
lange Wörter müssen Betten Ressourcen
und Personal vorgehalten werden etwas
was finanziell nur ein kostenpunkt ist
wenn es nicht zum Einsatz kommt da das
Gesundheitssystem aber auch vor fit
Orientierung und damit auch auf sparen
ausgelegt wurde wurden jahrzehntelang
Betten und Personal abgebaut selten
wurde deutlicher dass das System ist
dysfunktional und gewissermaßen ein
moralisches Desaster es liegt an uns es
zu dann sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
und das hat auch zur Folge dass auf
verschiedensten Ebenen bereits
vortriagiert wird wenn du noch wenige
bettenfreie sind dann wird eben schon
vor dem letzten Bett entschieden wer die
knappe Ressource eine Intensivbehandlung
bekommt und wer manchmal eben auch nicht
das System fördert solche Entscheidungen
auch wenn ein Großteil des medizinischen
Personals natürlich auch in diesem
System ihr Möglichstes versucht häufig
auf Kosten der eigenen psychischen und
physischen Gesundheit meine Damen und
Herren klar ist also jede Entscheidung
in die das medizinische Personal zu
einer solchen triageentscheidung
gezwungen wird ist eine Bankrott
Erklärung der Gesamtgesellschaft
vielleicht ist es da nur folgerichtig
dass auch der Bundestag selbst keine
gute Entscheidung treffen können wird
auf der einen Seite das was die
Regierung nun vorliegt der Entwurf
erlaubt auf Basis der kurzfristigen
Überlebenswahrscheinlichkeit der
Patientinnen zu entscheiden Herr Hilfe
hat das schon einige sehr richtige
Sachen gesagt
eigentlich gilt aber hat ein Mensch eine
Überlebenswahrscheinlichkeit wird er
behandelt wenn wir nun anfangen den Grad
der Überlebenswahrscheinlichkeit zu
vergleichen dann haben manche bestimmte
Personengruppen unvermeidbar Nachteile
dann diskriminieren wir auch wenn man
dem Gesetz den verzweifelthaften Versuch
ansieht Diskriminierung rauszuhalten
wird es niemals diskriminierungsfrei
sein und das ist mit der Würde des
Menschen nicht vereinbar sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren eine Variante die
einige Behindertenverbände vorgeschlagen
haben ist die Randomisierung diese
Variante überlässt die Entscheidung wenn
nun behandelt wird dem Zufall
gewissermaßen dem Schicksal das ist
keine zufriedenstellende Variante sie
kann es nicht sein aber immerhin wäre
sie diskriminierungsfrei eine
Entscheidung für das eine wie das andere
wird weiterhin zuvor gelagerten
triageentscheidungen führen denn das
medizinisch verantwortliche Personal
wird es sicher vermeiden übrigens über
unter weiterer Mehrbelastung solche
Entscheidungen so zu treffen so wir
unterbrechen an dieser Stelle denn die
Kollegen von der Tag haben auch einiges
zu berichten morgen sind wir natürlich
ab 8:45 Uhr wieder für Sie da da geht es
unter anderem um die aufsteckung des
Wirtschafts- und Stabilisierungsfonds um
200 Milliarden Euro jetzt geht es aber
erst einmal weiter mit Thomas Bade
25 Jahre Phönix das ganze Bild
Phoenix der Tag
guten Abend willkommen zu Phoenix der
Tag Deutschland hat ein Projekt zum
Aufbau eines besseren europäischen
luftverteidigungssystems auf den Weg
gebracht und es verteilungsministerin
Lambrecht unterzeichnete am Rand